I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello everybody! Hey, today is a big day, you guys. This is a very special episode of office, ladies. We are not breaking down an episode of The Office. Oh no. Well, you better buckle in. We're breaking down speed! Speed with Keanu Reeves and Sandra Bullock, Dennis Hopper, Jeff Daniels. Lady! I am very excited to break this down. We did a lot of research
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好！嘿，你们知道今天是个大日子。这是《办公室女郎》非常特别的一集。我们不打算剖析《办公室》的一集。哦，不。好吧，你们最好系好安全带。我们要剖析《生死时速》！由基努·里维斯、桑德拉·布洛克、丹尼斯·霍珀、杰夫·丹尼尔斯主演的《生死时速》。女士们！我非常兴奋来剖析这部电影。我们做了很多研究
for this. We have watched speed more times in a row than I thought I ever would. So much. I was telling Sam and Cassie this last week I've been having a little trouble sleeping. I think it is the cortisol from watching these tense bus chase scenes for five days and nights. But I'll tell you one thing. This movie holds up. It really does. I have watched all of these behind-the-scenes, making of videos where I watched them intricately perform all these stunts as part of my research today. And yet when I watch the movie, it's seamless. I am so impressed by this movie. I cannot believe the stunts they did and that the actors did them. We're going to get to it. Here's the research I did. Ready, folks? Yes. Got an
为了这个。我们连续看《生死时速》的次数比我想象的还要多。看了太多遍了。我上周告诉萨姆和卡西，我最近有点失眠。我想是因为连续五天五夜看这些紧张的公交车追逐场景产生的皮质醇。但我告诉你一件事。这部电影经得起时间考验。真的经得起。我看了所有这些幕后制作视频，看他们作为今天研究的一部分，错综复杂地完成所有这些特技。然而当我再次看这部电影时，它是那么天衣无缝。我对这部电影印象太深刻了。我简直不敢相信他们做的那些特技，以及演员们自己完成了这些特技。我们要讲到这个了。这是我做的研究。准备好了吗，各位？是的。我有一个
old tech alert for you. I got the DVDs with the extras. Of course you did. I love it. Let me tell you what is on this DVD extras because it's worth it. Audio commentary with the director, Jan de Bont. Audio commentary with writer, Graham Yost and producer, Mark Gordon. Action sequences behind-the-scenes footage and interviews with director and stunt coordinator, Gary Himes. Behind-the-scenes of all the stunts on the subway train. Inside speed on location stunts, visual effects, HBO, first look, the making of speed, extended scenes, trailers and TV spots, gallery of photos and a music video by Billy Idol. Wow. And guess what? Your little tiny blonde middle-aged lady watched all of it. I have seen all of
旧科技警报要告诉你。我买到了带花絮的DVD。你当然买了。我太喜欢了。让我告诉你这张DVD花絮里有什么，因为太值了。有导演扬·德·邦特的音频解说。编剧格雷姆·约斯特和制片人马克·戈登的音频解说。动作场面幕后花絮以及对导演兼特技统筹加里·海姆斯的采访。地铁列车上所有特技的幕后花絮。深入了解生死时速外景特技、视觉效果、HBO幕后首探、生死时速制作特辑、未删减场景、预告片和电视宣传片、照片库以及比利·偶像的音乐录影带。哇。你猜怎么着？你这个金发碧眼的中年小个子女人把所有的都看完了。我已经把所有这些
this. Oh my goodness. Also, you guys, I want you to know the director, Jan, was a former cinematographer. He had worked on Hunt for Red October, Die Hard, Basic Instinct, Lethal Weapon 3. He would operate the camera himself in this movie a ton, like handheld camera. And this was his directorial debut, right? Yes, that's right. And he would just grab the camera and be like, guys, I got to get in there. Let me operate this camera. He would pull focus. He would even slate for himself on the bus. I saw many behind-the-scenes videos and he gave an interview where he said they could fit so few people on the bus besides the cast that you kind of had to do more than one job. Yeah. And so, yeah, he did the clicker
都看过了。噢天哪。另外，各位，我想让你们知道，导演扬曾经是一名摄影师。他曾参与过《猎杀红色十月》、《虎胆龙威》、《本能》、《致命武器3》。在这部电影中，他经常自己操作摄像机，比如手持摄像机。这也是他的导演处女作，对吧？是的，没错。他就会直接抓起摄像机说，伙计们，我得进去。让我来操作这个摄像机。他会拉焦。他甚至还在公交车上自己打板。我看到了许多幕后视频，他在一次采访中说，除演员外，公交车上能容纳的人实在太少了，以至于你不得不身兼数职。是的。所以，是的，他按响了打板器
and all the things. He did all the things and he really wanted you to feel like you were in these shots with them. So that's why he was up up in their business with the handheld. Well, we have one more exciting thing to tell you. Also, we interviewed Beth Grant. You know her as Dwight's babysitter and date to the dinner party on the office. Yes. You guys, she's on the bus. She's on the bus. She's the lady who gets blown up trying to get off the bus when she shouldn't. Yeah. So we had the loveliest interview with her and we are going to release that as a bonus episode in a couple of days. It's so good. You have to listen to her behind-the-scenes stories. We have so much to cover in this speed breakdown
以及所有事情。他包揽了所有事情，他真的希望你能感觉自己和他们一起置身于这些镜头中。所以这就是为什么他拿着手持摄像机离他们那么近。好吧，我们还有一件激动人心的事要告诉你。另外，我们采访了贝丝·格兰特。你在《办公室》里认识她是德怀特的保姆兼晚餐派对的女伴。是的。伙计们，她在公交车上。她在公交车上。她就是那个试图下车却不该下车结果被炸飞的女士。是的。所以我们和她进行了一次非常愉快的采访，我们将在几天后作为特别单集发布。真的太棒了。你们一定要听听她的幕后故事。我们在这次《生死时速》剖析中有太多内容要涵盖了
that we wanted to give Beth a standalone. Should we get started? We better. My document's 45 pages. Oh, dear. Here we go. Buckle in, everyone. Speed, written by Graham Yost, directed by Jan DeBont, produced by Mark Gordon with a running time of 116 minutes. Here's your summary. A madman has rigged an LA bus with a bomb. If the bus drops below 50 miles per hour, the bomb will go off, killing everyone on board. He wants $3.7 million in cash or he's going to blow up the bus. That's it. Yeah. It's simple. It's simple. Fast fact number one. Graham Yost said that the original title for this movie was Minimum Speed. No. Yeah, Minimum Speed. No, that's not a good... What? You guys, I want you to go the Minimum
以至于我们想给贝丝一个单独的特辑。我们开始吧？我们最好开始。我的文档有45页。哦，天哪。我们走吧。大家系好安全带。《生死时速》，格雷姆·约斯特编剧，扬·德·邦特导演，马克·戈登制片，片长116分钟。这是你的剧情梗概。一个疯子在洛杉矶的一辆公交车上装了炸弹。如果公交车速度降到每小时50英里以下，炸弹就会爆炸，车上所有人都会丧命。他想要370万美元现金，否则他就会炸毁公交车。就是这样。是的。很简单。很简单。冷知识一。格雷姆·约斯特说这部电影最初的片名是《最低速度》。不会吧。是的，《最低速度》。不，这不是一个好……什么？伙计们，我想让你们选择《最低
Speed. He said he changed it when he realized it probably wasn't a good idea to have the word Minimum in a movie title. That's so funny. Graham was a writer on Full House when he wrote the script. He was a TV writer. He was inspired by the Akira Kurosawa movie, Runaway Train. And he thought, well, what if we put a bomb on a bus? He wrote this movie on spec. That means he wrote it for free in his free time. And then he took it out to the studios and shopped it around. Speed was shot in September of 1993, making this the 30th anniversary of the filming of Speed. And we talked to Beth about that, how it's been 30 years. That is crazy. Also, I want you guys to know many people on the commentaries talked about how
速度》。他说当他意识到在电影片名中使用“最低”这个词可能不是个好主意时，他把它改了。太搞笑了。格雷姆写这个剧本时是《欢乐满屋》的编剧。他是一名电视编剧。他受到黑泽明电影《暴走列车》的启发，他想，嗯，如果我们把炸弹放在公交车上会怎么样？他凭空写了这部电影。这意味着他在空闲时间免费写了它。然后他把它拿到各大制片厂去推销。《生死时速》于1993年9月拍摄，这使得今年成为《生死时速》拍摄30周年。我们和贝丝谈过这件事，谈到已经过去30年了。这太疯狂了。另外，我想让你们知道，评论音轨中的许多人谈到了当时天气有多热，因为9月是加州最热的月份，他们在9月的高速公路上。在一辆公交车上。在一辆公交车上。然后在场景之间，他们会待在高速公路路边。是的，这让我想起我们站在邓德米夫林停车场外面穿着厚重大衣，假装是冬天，而实际上天气非常非常热。我们就像《生死时速》一样。你和我，我们是《办公室》的演员。不过你知道吗，所有人都一直被困在公交车里，这让我想起了我们的会议室场景。我知道。我确实想到了。我想，我懂了为什么你在一个房间里待上一整天就会变得暴躁。是的。如果《办公室》的演员阵容重拍一部《生死时速》会怎么样？听我说完。
hot it was because September is our hottest month in California and they were on a free way in September. On a bus. On a bus. And then in between scenes, they'd be like on the side of the freeway. Yes, this reminded me of us standing outside in our heavy coats in the Dunder Mifflin parking lot pretending like it was winter when really it was so, so hot. We are just like speed. You and I, we are cast on the office. You know what though, all the people are trapped in the bus all the time and it made me think of our conference room scenes. I know. I did think about that. I was like, I get how you get punchy in one room all day. Yeah. What if the cast of the office did a remake of Speed? Hear me out.
不用多说了。来吧。算我一个。对吧。这就是没人想到的重聚。德怀特是那个疯子。是的。当然。是的。托比试图逃跑。他被炸死了。我能开公交车吗？你来开公交车。迈克尔是那个讨厌的游客。哦，肯定的。对吧？是的。哦，天哪。哦，我现在脑子里有了所有角色的画面。我们能做到。我觉得我是那个拿着钱包把我们所有秘密都泄露出去的女士。我觉得克里德是那个拔枪的人，因为他觉得吉姆在追他。在追他。是的。是的。全都在这里了。大家看，这有画面了。我们需要跟谁谈谈这件事？我们需要找探照灯影业和环球影业这样的公司来合作。快给制片厂打电话。
Say no more. Come on. I'm in. Right. This is the reunion no one's thought of. Dwight is the mad man. Yes. Of course. Yes. Toby tries to escape. He gets killed. Do I get to drive the bus? You get to drive the bus. Michael is the annoying tourist. Oh, for sure. Right? Yeah. Oh my gosh. Oh, I'm seeing all the characters now. We can do it. I think I'm the lady with the purse that gives us all away. I think Creed is the one who pulls the gun because he thinks that Jim is after him. After him. Yes. Yeah. It's all there. It's coming together, you guys. Who do we need to talk to about this? We need to get it like Fox Searchlight and Universal to do a collab. Fire up the phone to the studio.
好吧，冷知识二，选角。你们想听点选角八卦吗？我想吗？好吧。那是什么声音？我不知道。我不知道。抓紧你们的帽子。我抓紧了。你真的戴着帽子。我知道，因为我后脑勺有个很难对付的旋。好吧，你戴帽子看起来很可爱，但抓紧了。好的。基努并不是他们这个角色的首选。你怎么敢？滚开。你怎么敢？那是谁？斯蒂芬·鲍德温。什么？是的。他拒绝了，因为他觉得这跟《虎胆龙威》太像了。哦，他觉得这就像是《虎胆龙威》的翻版。他们还找过汤姆·克鲁斯、汤姆·汉克斯、韦斯利·斯奈普斯和伍迪·哈里森。最后，他们决定跟一些演员见面谈这个角色，而基努就是他们见面的
All right. Fast fact number two, casting. You want some casting dish? Do I? All right. What is that voice? I don't know. I don't know. Hold on to your hats. I'm holding on. You are literally wearing a hat. I know because I have really bad back of the head Cal Lickday. Well, you look cute in the hat, but hold on to it. Okay. Keanu was not their first choice for the role. How dare you? Get out. How dare you? Who was? Stephen Baldwin. What? Yeah. He turned it down because he thought it was too similar to Die Hard. Oh, he felt like it was a Die Hard redo. They also went to Tom Cruise, Tom Hanks, Wesley Snipes and Woody Harrelson. Finally, they decided to meet with actors for the role and Keanu was one of
其中一个人。编剧说他骑着摩托车来到制片厂地块。是的。他留着飘逸、帅气的长发，他们基本上所有人对他的好感度瞬间达到顶峰。并且觉得，行吧，我们得把这个角色给他。正常人都会这样。没错。但看看这个。在他得到这个角色后，导演扬说，也许你想剪一个看起来更像警察的发型。他没有具体说明这意味着什么。于是基努出去剃了个平头。他在上班第一天来到片场，制片厂和制片人看着他，他们脑海中还留着他骑摩托车抵达时的记忆。他们心碎了。他们简直不敢相信这个平头。他们差点推迟拍摄
the people they met with. The screenwriter said he pulled up to the studio lot on a motorcycle. Yes. And he had like flowy, gorgeous hair and they all basically got a man crush on him immediately. And we're like, yeah, we're going to want to give him the role. As one does. That's right. But check this out. After he got the role, the director Yon said, maybe you want to get a little bit more of a cop looking haircut. He didn't specify what that meant. So Keanu went out and got a buzz cut. He showed up to the set on the first day of work and the studio and the producers, they looked at him, their memories of his motorcycle arrival. They're crushed. They couldn't believe this buzz cut. They almost postponed filming
这样他的头发就能长回来。是的。我知道。导演扬说你在电影里看到的其实已经长长了一点。噢天哪。我觉得他顶着那个发型看起来帅极了。我没有任何抱怨。我没有任何抱怨。我是说，我猜我无论如何都喜欢他的头发。就是这样。不管你的发型怎么变，基努。那张脸太棒了。我甚至不需要担心头发在搞什么鬼。它随时都管用。我们来聊聊安妮这个角色，正如我们所知，这个角色最终归属了极具魅力的桑德拉·布洛克。在这部电影里，她简直不能再可爱了。噢天哪，不可能更可爱了。说到开启某人的演艺生涯。是的。安妮这个角色最初是提供给
so he could grow his hair back. Yeah. I know. Yon, the director said that what you see in the movie is actually a little bit grown in. Oh my gosh. I thought he looked amazing with that haircut. I have no complaints. I have no complaints. I mean, I guess I think I like his hair anyway. There you go. Whatever your hair cell is, Keanu. The face is so great. I don't need to even worry about what's happening with the hair. It all works all the time. Let's talk about the role of Annie, which as we know, eventually went to the absolutely charming Sandra Bullock. She could not be more adorable in this movie. Oh my gosh, not possible. Talk about launching someone's career. Yeah. The role of Annie was originally offered to
哈莉·贝瑞的，但她拒绝了。她说，原话是，“我拒绝了《生死时速》，因为我想我不想开那辆公交车。”而且台词也不是很多。但后来她看了这部电影，她说她很喜欢。她心里想，哇，电影之神那天确实没理我。不，是她拒绝的那天。但她后来确实和基努合作了。是的，他们一起出演了《疾速追杀3》。是的，你没看过，但我看过。我知道。我们要去看《疾速追杀4》。我的《疾速追杀》系列电影有个巨大的空白。我直接跳到第四部。但这里有个疯狂的事。所以，曾被邀请饰演安妮的哈莉·贝瑞和曾被邀请饰演杰克的斯蒂芬·鲍德温，后来都去主演了
Halle Berry, but she turned it down. She said, quote, I turned down speed because I thought I don't want to drive that bus. And there wasn't a whole lot of dialogue. But then later she saw the movie and she said she loved it. And she thought to herself, wow, the movie gods sure didn't talk to me that day. No, the day she turned it down. But she does get to eventually start with Keanu. Yes, they start in John Wick 3. Yes, which you haven't seen, but I have. I know. And we're going to go see John Wick 4. We are big hole in my John Wick anthology. I'm just jumping to four. But here's something crazy. So Halle Berry, who was offered the role of Annie and Stephen Baldwin, who was offered the role of Jack, eventually went
《摩登原始人》。哦，原来如此。所以当哈莉·贝瑞拒绝后，编剧向艾伦·德杰尼勒斯提出了这个构思。他说他觉得也许让一个喜剧演员来演这个角色是个好主意。是的，我看到他说，你知道，当时有那种驾驶学校课程，就像喜剧驾驶学校一样。也许这个角色教的是喜剧驾驶技巧。这就是为什么她后来能开着公交车穿过车流。但她同时也很搞笑，喜欢讲笑话。好吧，最终有两打多知名女演员为这个角色试镜。当时，桑德拉·布洛克演过两个主角。她演过《灵药情缘》和《越战先锋》。她还得和基努进行
on to star in the Flintstones. Oh, there you go. So when Halle Berry passed, the writer pitched Ellen DeGeneres. He said he thought maybe like a comedian in the role would be a good idea. Yeah, I read that he said, you know, there were these driving school classes at the time that it was like a comedy driving school. And that maybe this character taught comedic driving lessons. And that's why she could drive a bus then through the traffic. But she also was funny and like cracking jokes. Well, eventually over two dozen big name actresses audition for the role. At this time, Sandra Bullock had done two lead roles. She had been in Love Potion number nine and Demolition Man. She still had to do a chemistry read
化学反应试镜。我猜他们表现惊艳。是的，每个人都说他们有惊艳的化学反应。她得到了这个角色。他们拍这部电影时都是29岁。拍完这部电影后，桑德拉·布洛克在2010年和2014年都成为了全球片酬最高的女演员。哇。是的，这是一件非常非常大的事。这是一件大事。好吧，说到配角阵容，当然，我们有丹尼斯·霍珀饰演我们的反派。是的。杰夫·丹尼尔斯在这部电影里表现太棒了。太棒了，哈里。还有乔·莫顿饰演麦克队长。我太喜欢他了。太棒了。太棒了。我们会在剖析中更多地讨论他们。但我们来看看冷知识三。我们看吧。这部电影的另一个主角，公交车。25号公交车，25号。他们为这部电影使用了12辆或
with Keanu. I guess they crushed it. Yes, everyone said they had amazing chemistry. She got the part. They were both 29 years old when they made this movie. And after this movie, Sandra Bullock went on to be the world's highest paid actress in both 2010 and 2014. Wow. Yeah, it was a big, big deal. It was a big deal. Well, rounding out the cast, of course, we have Dennis Hopper as our villain. Yes. Jeff Daniels, who is so good in this movie. So good, Harry. Yes. And also, Joe Morton as Captain Mack. I loved him. So good. So good. We'll discuss more about them in our breakdown. But let's get to Fast Back number three. Let's. The other star of this movie, the bus. Bus 25, 25. They used 12 or
13辆公交车。我们在我观看的所有官方幕后资料中讨论过，他们反复说有12辆公交车。是的。好吧，我想让你们知道，在导演的评论音轨中，他说的是13辆公交车。安吉拉和我做研究时可能为此起了一点小争执。可能吧。珍娜说，有12辆。我说，不，有13辆。她说，女士，女士，女士。我已经听了某某和某某和某某和某某。而我说，我在听导演的。好吧，我把我观看的所有视频中的公交车列了个清单。你做你的清单。然后我来告诉你导演是怎么说的。我追踪到了12辆，也许13辆。有时他们说“几辆”。我不知
13 buses for this movie. We discussed in all of the official behind the scenes material that I watched. They repeatedly say there were 12 buses. Yes. Well, I want you to know in the director's commentary, he says 13 buses. Angela and I might have gotten in a tiny argument about this while doing our research. Might have. Jenna's like, there's 12. I said, no, there's 13. She's like, lady, lady, lady. I have listened to so and so and so and so and so and so. And I'm like, I'm listening to the director. Well, I made a list of all the buses from all the videos I watched. You do your list. And then I'm going to tell you what the director said. And I tracked 12, maybe 13. Sometimes they say a couple. And I don't
道“几辆”是两辆还是三辆。对吧，“几辆”。好吧，这是我收集到的：两辆用于外景拍摄的公交车。当我们看到公交车时，公交车在高速公路上行驶的长镜头，显然是用直升机拍摄的，其中两辆是这样的；两辆用于撞击东西的特技公交车。其中一辆经过改装，开得非常非常快。另一辆用来撞击各种东西。太棒了。然后有一辆公交车改装了特殊的液压系统，使其能够倾斜到两个轮子上。它的一侧实际上连接在一辆皮卡车上，这样它在用两个轮子行驶时就不会真正翻倒。这是一辆完全特殊的公交车。有一辆公交车被剥离得非常
know if what is that is a couple to is a couple three. Right. A couple. Well, here's what I've got two buses for exterior photography. When we see the bus, long shot of the bus going down the highway, clearly shot by a helicopter, two of those buses, two stunt buses that they used for running into things. One of those was rigged to just go really super fast. And one of them knocked into stuff. Great. Then there was a bus that was rigged with special hydraulics so it could tilt up onto two wheels. And one side of it was actually attached to a pickup truck so that it would not actually tip over when it went up on two wheels. That was a whole special bus. One bus that was stripped down to be made very,
非常轻，用来进行跨越高速公路断桥的那次飞跃。一辆在电影开头被炸毁的公交车，一辆在飞机下被炸毁的公交车，两辆内部公交车。这是他们用于拍摄车内演员所有镜头的公交车。其中一辆公交车的前面有一个巨大的平台，里面包裹着有机玻璃。这个平台支撑着摄像机组和扬，这样他们就可以拍进公交车里，同时还能有自然光照进来。他们一遍又一遍地称它为“教皇移动车”。整个剧组都这么叫它，因为你知道那个透明玻璃小推车的东西吗？是的。还有一辆工艺公交车，离地更高，用于基努在公交车底下的所有镜头。还有一辆车架公交车。我不知道那是什么。而且我也无法确定到底有一辆还是两辆。但我们假设有一辆，那就是12辆公交车。安吉拉，你的第13辆公交车在哪里？好的。在这里，珍娜。扬说大飞跃的第一条，你知道的，那次大飞跃。高速公路大飞跃。那次宏大的高速公路大飞跃。第一次拍摄时，特技司机错过了坡道，把公交车撞了。噢天哪。任何幕后资料里都没有这个。然后他在评论音轨里有些轻声地说，我从来没告诉制片厂，因为他们只有一次机会。所以两天后，我们又弄了一辆公交车，再次尝试，司机飞跃并完美落地。
very light for that jump across the missing piece of highway. One bus to blow up at the beginning of the movie, one bus to blow up under the plane, two interior buses. This is what they used for all of the filming of the cast inside the bus. One of those buses had this giant platform on the front of the bus that was like encased in plexiglass. And that held the camera crew and yawn so that they could shoot into the bus but still have natural light coming in. They called it the Pope Mobile over and over again. That's what the whole crew called it because you know the little clear glass buggy cart thing. Yes. There was also a process bus which was higher off the ground for all the shots
这就是你的第13辆公交车。那是第13辆公交车吗？是的，那是第13辆公交车。我想制片厂肯定没有听扬的导演评论音轨。我太喜欢了。虽然没人受伤，但他们第一次尝试时错过了坡道。好吧，我有很多关于他们是如何完成那次飞跃的非常酷的细节，你以为你知道。好吧，我们知道。因为你看到的是两个把《生死时速》搜得底朝天的女性，包括既然我们在谈论公交车，还有这张电影的原版海报。原版海报上只有两个形象。有谁能猜到吗？基努和桑德拉。基努和公交车。什么？是的。他们完全把她切掉了。你知道吗？他们不知道她会爆炸。他们不知道。
when Keanu was under the bus. And then a carcass bus. I don't know what that is. And I also could not nail down if there were one or two of those. But let's say there was one, that's 12 buses. Angela wears your 13th bus. Okay. Here it is, Jenna. Yawn said the first take of the big jump, you know, the big, big jump. The highway jump. The big highway jump. On the first take, the stunt driver missed the ramp and crashed the bus. Oh my gosh. That is not on any of the behind the scenes material. Then he sort of quietly says on the commentary, I never told the studio because they only had one chance to do this. So two days later, we got another bus and we did it again and the driver jumped and landed it perfectly.
他们不知道。也许这词用得不对。没错。她会一飞冲天。不。不。她会成为超级巨星。一举成名。是的。好吧，我们休息一下。回来后，我们有很多关于电梯的冷知识。哦，太多了。我们回来了，我们要以一段三分钟多的演职员表序列来开始这部电影。我们将从41层一直下到地下室的电梯井。事情是这样的，伙计们。这个电梯井是一个微缩模型。它是市中心一栋大楼里他们正在拍摄的一个电梯井的精致、直接的复制品。是的。这是一个由格兰特·麦昆设计公司创作的85英尺长的微缩模型。
There's your 13th bus. Is that bus 13? Yes, that is bus 13. And I guess the studio has not listened to Yawn's director's commentary. I love it. No one was injured in the crash, but they missed the ramp on the first try. Well, I have a bunch of really cool details on how they did that jump, which you think you do. Well, we do. Because you're looking at two ladies who googled the shiitake out of speed, including since we're talking about the bus, the original movie poster for this. There were only two images on the original movie poster. Any guesses? Keanu and Sandra. Keanu and the bus. What? Yes. They totally cut her out. You know what? They didn't know she was going to explode. They didn't know.
它由八个电梯井组成，有一个运转的电梯轿厢和400根微型荧光灯管作为光源。他们花了快一个星期来拍摄这三分钟的镜头。我看过幕后花絮。是的。关于他们是如何制作的。这些家伙，他们真是累瘫了。他们说他们有一个剧组每周工作7天，每天工作18到20小时。他们睡在制片厂建这个模型附近的酒店里。超级紧张。是的。还有一件事，伙计们。这个85英尺长的微缩电梯井，他们必须把它水平放置，他们的设计是，当摄像机从一个楼层移动到下一个楼层时，也就是演职员表中出现新的人名的时候。在这漫长的一段电梯井跟踪镜头的最后，它会在一门门前结束。而你一旦穿过那扇门，你就进入了真实尺寸的检修门。这太神奇了。好吧。我们准备好进入这部电影的第一幕了吗？《生死时速》包含三个主要的动作序列，电梯序列、公交车序列和地铁序列。制片人马克·戈登说他在看完电梯序列后就想买下这个剧本。我懂。太棒了。是的。在第一场戏中，我们在地下室。看起来有人在修理电梯，但大楼保安说，等等，你是谁？你在干什么？你的工单呢？然后他的太阳穴被一把螺丝刀刺中了。
They didn't know. Maybe not the right word for this. Correct. That she was going to blow up. No. No. That she was going to become a superstar. Rise to stardom. Yeah. Well, let's take a break. And when we get back, we have a lot of elevator facts. Oh, so many. We are back and we are going to start this movie with a credit sequence that is a little over three minutes long. We are going to go down an elevator shaft starting at floor 41 all the way to the basement. Here's the thing, you guys. This elevator shaft was a miniature. It was a elaborate, direct replica of one of the elevator shafts they were filming in a building downtown. Yes. It was an 85 foot long miniature created by Grant McCune Design.
是的，非常残酷的开场。这就是我们遇到丹尼斯·霍珀的时候，他饰演霍华德·佩恩，一个在服役期间失去大拇指的亚特兰大退休警官。你们猜怎么着，伙计们？他想要报复。他确实想。但他在干什么？我们还不知道。我们还不知道。他在图谋不轨。我们知道这一点。我们当然知道。珍娜，你知道丹尼斯·霍珀直到拍摄第三周才被选定吗？他们拍了这部电影三周却没有反派？是的。这对我来说太疯狂了。好吧，他们有很多事要做。也许他们在微缩电梯井里花了一周时间。好吧，我注意到的一件事是，在这部电影中，丹尼斯·霍珀几乎没有与其他人类的对手戏。他几乎全是在他那间挂满监视器的奇怪公寓里打电话。是的。我是说，他做了很多电话表演。是的。而且表现极其出色。你猜怎么着？一群高管刚刚在楼上开完了一场非常成功的董事会会议。他们非常高兴。是的。他们要挤进电梯。鲍勃要按一个按钮。哦，鲍勃，你按了哪个按钮，鲍勃？我知道。鲍勃由帕特里克·费斯勒饰演，而给鲍勃找麻烦的那个人是罗伯特·梅尔豪斯，他与基努·里维斯是另类摇滚乐队“狗星”的创始人之一。没错。他是鼓手。在鲍勃按了按钮之后，我们在地下室的那个疯子将炸毁缆绳，电梯将开始直线下坠，直到紧急
It was made up of eight shafts with one working elevator car and 400 mini fluorescent tubes as lights. It took them over a week to shoot this three minutes of footage. I watched behind the scenes. Yes. On how they did it. And these guys, they were so fried. They said they had a crew working seven days a week, 18 to 20 hours a day. They slept in a hotel near where this model had been built at the studio. Super intense. Yeah. And here's the other thing, you guys. The miniature elevator shaft, 85 feet of it, they had to lay it horizontally and they designed it so that as the camera travels from one floor to the next floor, that's in the title sequence when a new person's name would appear. And at the very end of this
刹车启动。哦，不。我是说，说“哦，不”一点没错。但别担心，特工队到了，天哪，他们真的到了吗？我们看到一辆车飞过空中，然后毫无必要地着陆。毫无必要地。导演说他想要这种动作的开场镜头。通常对于主角，你只展示主角，对吧？你只是推镜头到你的主角演员身上，但他想要汽车飞跃来表明：这部电影是关于动作的。基努·里维斯从驾驶座下来。杰夫·丹尼尔斯从副驾驶座下来。他们走到后备箱。他们开始穿上所有的特工装备。是的。基努在采访中说，穿上所有这些装备真的很酷。好吧，我查了一下。我想，这些装备有多重？因为他们马上要在这些装备下跑过无数层楼梯。所以我必须知道。它重16磅，就像军用级硬质防弹背心一样重16磅。这很重。确实很重。是的。扬说他真的希望特工队的主演和背景演员尽可能地真实。他实际上让突击队员随时在片场提供咨询。他说一旦他们穿上装备，甚至连走路的方式都会改变，还有耳机以及他们彼此交谈的方式。太惊人了。好吧，正如我们所说，麦克队长由乔·莫顿饰演，他是一位获得过托尼奖提名的演员，而且简直棒极了。他要向我们通报正在发生的事情。
long tracking shot down the elevator shaft, it would end on this door. And the minute you go through that door, now you're in the real size, the service door. That is amazing. All right. Are we ready to get into the first act of this movie? Speed consists of three primary action sequences, the elevator sequence, the bus sequence and the subway sequence. Producer Mark Gordon said he wanted to buy the script after reading the elevator sequence. I get it. It's so good. Yes. In the first scene, we are in the basement. It looks like someone is maybe fixing an elevator, but building security says, wait, who are you? What are you doing? Where's your work order? And he gets stabbed in the side of the head with
有一部载有13名乘客的电梯。它被安装了炸药。他们成了人质，因为设置炸弹的人索要300万美元作为赎金。他们给了一个小时来完成这件事，但时钟已经在滴答作响，现在他们只剩下23分钟了。所以杰克自愿让哈里去检查炸弹。他确实去了。扬谈到了电影中的一个编剧技巧，叫做“设定时钟”。在这部电影的始终，都会有一个时钟在滴答作响，无论是23分钟，还是他们只剩10分钟，或者他们只剩6分钟的燃料。总是会有时钟的提醒。我是说，还有车速表也是这部电影中一种滴答作响的时钟。这就是为什么我认为
a screwdriver. Yeah. Very brutal opening. This is when we meet Dennis Hopper, who plays Howard Payne, a retired Atlanta police officer who lost his thumb and service. And guess what guys? He's wanting payback. He is. But what's he doing? We don't know yet. We don't know. He's up to no good. We know that. We sure do. Jenna, did you know that Dennis Hopper wasn't cast until the third week of filming? They shot three weeks of this movie without a villain? Yeah. That is bonkers to me. Well, they had a lot to do. Maybe they spent a week in the elevator miniature shaft. Well, something I noticed is that Dennis Hopper has almost no scenes with other human beings in this movie. He is almost exclusively on the phone
我一直无法入睡。我知道。因为我在这部电影滴答作响的时钟下待了太久。好吧，哈里和杰克将爬进电梯井，他们会在轿厢顶部发现炸药。他们开始试图弄清楚在这里该做点什么。他们进行了第一次突击测验。你想做吗？我打印出来了，安吉拉。我想吗？好吧。我想做突击测验吗？这就像是我最喜欢的电影里的保留桥段。好吧。我当哈里。你当杰克。准备好了吗？哦，我来演基努。你可以演基努。好的。好的。好吧。突击测验。机场。一个歹徒挟持一个人质。他用她作掩护。他快走到飞机跟前了。你离他一百英尺远。开枪
in his weird apartment with all the monitors. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, he did a lot of phone acting. Yeah. And incredibly so. Guess what? A bunch of executives have had a very successful board meeting upstairs. They're very happy. Yeah. They're going to cram into the elevator. Bob is going to press a button. Oh, Bob, what button did you press, Bob? I know. Bob was played by Patrick Fischler and the guy giving Bob grief is Robert Mailhouse, who is one of the founders of the alternative rock band Dog Star with Keanu Reeves. That's right. He was the drummer. After Bob presses the button, our madman in the basement is going to blow up the cables and the elevator is going to start plummeting until the emergency
击毙人质。什么？把她从方程式中剔除。瞄准一个好伤口，这样他就没法带着她上飞机了。清晰的射击角度。你脑子彻底坏掉了。你知道吗？女士，这部电影上映后，我和我的朋友们总是对彼此说“突击测验”。当然。就像跑腿时，比如去杂货店时。突击测验。今晚你想烤热狗还是汉堡？我觉得这是电影中比较容易被人引用的台词之一。肯定的。杰克将弄清楚如何化解这种局面。如何将人质从方程式中剔除。是的。这里有个巨大的，你管那个叫什么？起重机？大楼顶上有一个起重机，他说，我们弄根缆绳。
brakes kick on. Uh-oh. I mean, uh-oh is right. But don't worry, the SWAT team is arriving and oh, do they arrive? We see a car fly through the air and like land unnecessarily. Unnecessarily. The director said he wanted this establishing shot of action. Normally with your lead, you established just the lead, right? You just push in on your lead actor, but he wanted the car jumping to be like, this movie is about action. Keanu Reeves is going to get out of the driver's seat. Jeff Daniels gets out of the passenger seat. They go to the trunk. They start putting on all their SWAT gear. Yeah. Keanu in an interview said it was really cool to wear all that gear. Well, I looked it up. I was like, how much does
我们跑上去。我们把这个放下来。我们把它系在电梯上。好吧，如你所知，剧透警告，这个起重机的想法一开始会起作用，但最终坚持不住。我们马上会讲到。但当杰克说，“电梯有多重？”并有了这个想法时，我查了一下。电梯到底有多重？好吧，根据网站weightofstuff.com，这是一个专门列出不同物品重量的整个网站，列出了平均重量。还记得那个大卫·莱特曼的恶搞环节吗，他会去说，嗯，这是一艘船，嗯，它浮着。记住，我觉得这个网站就是weightofstuff.com。如果你曾经好奇的话，一个空
that gear weigh? Because they're about to run up like a gazillion flights of stairs in that gear. So I had to know. It weighs 16 pounds like military grade hard plate vests weigh 16 pounds. That's a lot. It really is. Yeah. Yon said he really wanted the main characters and the background performers for the SWAT team to be as authentic as possible. He actually had squad officers on set at all times to consult with. He said once they put the gear on, even how you walk changes and the earpiece and how they talk to one another. Amazing. Well, Captain Mack, who as we said was played by Joe Morton, who is a Tony nominated actor and who is just fantastic. He's going to give us the lowdown on what's happening.
电梯的平均重量在2,000到6,000磅之间。这很重。那只是个空电梯。我们里面有13名人质。顺便说一句，人质们有点吓坏了。电梯里的气氛非常紧张。所以他们系上了钩子，基努·里维斯是倒挂着的。他真的那样做了。伙计们，他真的倒挂在那些缆绳上。我差点谷歌了“安全倒挂能持续多久”，但我放弃了。好吧，不管怎样。这些都是我想到的事情。所以我们的疯子会意识到他们在搞鬼，他会炸断刹车。这在电梯底部炸出了一个洞。电梯一直直线下坠到第23层，这时我们的起重机终于
There is an elevator with 13 passengers. It is rigged with explosives. They are hostages because the person who set the bomb is demanding $3 million as a payout. They gave them an hour to get this done, but the clock has already been ticking and now they only have 23 minutes left. So Jack is going to volunteer Harry to go inspect the bomb. He is. Yon talked about a writer's trick that they do in movies called set the clock. And throughout this movie, there'll be a clock ticking, whether it's 23 minutes or they only have 10 minutes or they only have six minutes of fuel. There's always the reminder of the clock. I mean also just the speedometer is a kind of ticking clock in this movie too. This is why I think
抓住了。电梯里有那么多的混乱和恐慌。你曾被困在电梯里过吗？我从来没有，但这给我的感觉就像它发生在我身上一样，简直是创伤后应激障碍。不，太吓人了。我从来没有被困在电梯里过，但是女士，导演分享了他在《虎胆龙威》拍摄期间发生的一件事，那件事启发了他创作这个场景。你必须听听这个。《虎胆龙威》启发了《生死时速》。我太喜欢这个了。我之所以构思出这个我刚才开始讲的整个电梯场景，是因为在拍摄《虎胆龙威》期间，我自己曾有一次被困在电梯里。我是说，那实际上是在福克斯广场大楼，而且真的非常诡异。我们坐在第40层，等待
I haven't been able to sleep. I know. Because I've been under the ticking clock of this movie for so long. Well, Harry and Jack are going to climb into the elevator shaft and they're going to find the explosives on the top of the car. They're going to start trying to figure out what to do here. They do their first pop quiz. Do you want to do it? I printed it out, Ange. Do I? All right. Do I want to do the pop quiz? This is like my favorite runner of the movie. All right. I'll be Harry. You be Jack. Ready? Oh, I get to be Keanu. You can be Keanu. Okay. Okay. All right. Pop quiz. The airport. Gunman with one hostage. He's using her for cover. He's almost to a plane. You're a hundred feet away. Shoot
了几个小时，最后消防部门来了，通过顶部把我们救了出去，我们不得不爬出去，从一个电梯跳到另一个电梯。那件事在我脑海里挥之不去，持续了非常非常长的时间。里面感觉太让人感到幽闭恐惧了。你知道，你周围所有那些人，温度很快就升高了。要保持镇静非常困难。我是说，如果任何人会恐慌，那马上就会陷入混乱。这是一种有些创伤性的经历，那种幽闭恐惧的感觉。我觉得这会是，你知道的，这对于这种类型、对于这部电影、对于我的电影来说会是个完美的点子。我想确保人们能对它感同身受。噢天哪。是的。你敢相信吗？他在拍《虎胆龙威》时被困在
the hostage. What? Take her out of the equation. Go for the good wound and he can't get to the plane with her. Clear shot. You're deeply nuts. You know that? Lady, after this movie came out, my friends and I would say pop quiz all the time to each other. Of course. Like just like running errands, like going to the grocery store. Pop quiz. Do you want to grill hot dogs tonight or hamburgers? I feel like it's one of the more like quotable moments from the movie. For sure. Jack is going to figure out how to diffuse the situation. How to take the hostages out of the equation. Yes. There's this giant, what do you call that thing? A crane? A crane on top of the building and he's like, let's get a cable.
电梯里，然后他用那段经历来为《生死时速》提供灵感。是的。这也许是我听过的最喜欢的冷知识了。他太迷人了。我可以说在所有那些DVD花絮中，最棒的东西就是扬的评论音轨，还有所有特技的幕后花絮。比利·偶像的音乐录影带呢？我会跳过它。好吧，听着，就像我说的，起重机撑不住了，但他们会试图把所有的乘客从这个狭小的空间里救出来，因为电梯继续发出“咕噜咕噜”的声音，就像在下坠。是的。扬指出，他很喜欢这个电梯序列中的声音设计，因为他真的希望电梯能成为它自己的一个角色，发出呻吟和这种非常可怕的声音，他
We're going to run up there. We're going to loop this down. We're going to attach it to the elevator. Well, as you know, spoiler alert, this crane idea is going to work at first, but it's not ultimately going to hold. We'll get there. But when Jack says, how much does an elevator weigh? And he gets this idea, I looked it up. How much does an elevator weigh? Well, according to the website, weightofstuff.com, it's an entire website that just lists the weights of different items, the average weight. Do you remember that Letterman bit where he would go, well, it's seeing her, well, it floats. Remember, this is, I feel like this website, weightofstuff.com. If you're ever curious, the average weight of an empty
认为声音设计团队太棒了。它产生了和《侏罗纪公园》里你听到霸王龙声音时一样的效果。是的。就像电梯本身就是一种怪物。是的。你知道的，有一个女人不想离开电梯。不。她由苏珊·巴恩斯饰演，讽刺的是，她在《生死时速2》中再次出场饰演康斯坦斯。哦，是吗？是的。她被困在什么东西里必须被拉出来吗？我没看过《生死时速2》，所以我还不太确定。我也没看过。我们会看吗？我有点觉得我应该去看看，因为，好吧，是这样的。当我被1800 Dentist录用时，我在进行培训，有一个故事，有点像传奇故事。
elevator ranges from 2,000 to 6,000 pounds. That's a lot. That's an empty elevator. We've got 13 hostages inside. Well, by the way, the hostages are kind of freaking out. It's very tense in the elevator. So they attach the hook, Keanu Reeves is upside down. He really did that. He really hung upside down on those cables, you guys. I almost googled how long can you safely hang upside down, but I let it go. Well, okay. Anyway, these are the things I think of. So our madman is going to realize that they're up to something and he is going to blow the brakes. This blows out a hole in the bottom of the elevator. The elevator starts plummeting all the way down to the 23rd floor when our crane finally
那里以前有个操作员在我之前工作，他有一天来上班时说，去你的，吃屎吧。老子不干了，因为我被《生死时速2》选上了。我要上船了。所以少废话。我辞职了。我不知道是不是那么戏剧化，但就像他辞职了。他要去船上待两个月。他拍了两个月，女士。然后当电影上映时，所有的操作员都在说，哦，天哪，我们得去看看那个家伙，巴拉巴拉。他们去看电影了，我就问，电影怎么样？他们说，他不在里面。哦，天哪。我就想，什么？他被剪掉了。里面有就像他的肩膀。他的肩膀在里面，就像在背景里出现了五秒钟。
catches. There is so much mayhem and panic inside this elevator. Have you ever been trapped inside of an elevator? I never have, but this gives me PTSD as if it happened to me. No, it's so scary. I have never been trapped in an elevator, but lady, the director shared about something that happened to him on Die Hard that inspired him for this scene. You've got to hear it. Die Hard inspired speed. I love this. The reason I came up this whole elevator scene that I started to say earlier is that during the filming of Die Hard, I once myself got stuck in an elevator. I mean, it was actually at the building of the Fox Plaza building, and it was really eerie. We were sitting on the 40th floor and waited
我就想，哦，天哪。所以我觉得我需要去看看。我得去看看那个肩膀男。女士，这太让我想起我被选为国际辣妹组合第六名的时候了。什么？记得吗？但它其实是个，就像是应召女郎团伙的幌子。我在播客里讲过那个故事。我知道，我突然以为你被选进了一部电影，然后被剪掉了。
for hours and finally the fire department came and took us out via the top and we had to climb out and jump from one elevator to the other elevator. And that has stuck with me for a very, very long time. It feels so incredibly claustrophobic in there. You know, all those people around you, it gets hot very quickly. It's very hard to stay calm. I mean, if anybody would panic, it would instantly be chaotic. This was a kind of a traumatic experience and that whole feeling of claustrophobia. I thought this would be, you know, that would be like a deal for this type of, for this film, for my movie. I wanted to make sure that people could identify with it. Oh my gosh. Yeah. Can you believe that? He got stuck in
没有，抱歉。不，那是当我将要成为一名国际辣妹时，我一直在跟人们解释，比如说，我不知道我能不能去参加你的婚礼。我可能在巡演。你知道，就像是，我甚至不知道我今年感恩节能不能回家。我们可能要进行很多排练。你知道，我告诉我的老板，我现在可以呆在这，但最终。是的。这家伙就是这么做的。他告诉了所有人，就像所有人，我要去演《生死时速2》了。我生活中的每个人。
an elevator while filming Die Hard and then he used that experience to inform speed. Yeah. This is maybe my favorite fact ever. He's fascinating. I would say of all of those DVD extras, the best thing on it is Jan's commentary and also all of the behind the scenes of the stunts. What about the Billy Idol music video? I would skip it. Well, listen, like I said, the crane is not going to hold, but they are going to try to get all the passengers out of this tiny space as it continues to kind of like goog-goog-goog, like fall. Yes. Jan pointed out he loved the sound design in this elevator sequence because he really wanted the elevator to be its own character groaning and making these really scary noises and he
是的。是的。是的。然后每个人都问，嘿，后来怎么样了，你就会说，哦，我不想谈这个。我被剪掉了。所以他们刚好在最后一刻救出了所有人。我是说，苏珊丢了一只鞋。她没丢一只脚算她走运。
thought the sound design team crushed it. It had the same effect as like in Jurassic Park when you would hear the sounds of the T-Rex. Yeah. It's like the elevator was its own kind of monster. Yeah. You know, there's one woman who doesn't want to leave the elevator. No. She was played by Susan Barnes who ironically turns up again and speed to cruise control as Constance. Oh yeah? Yeah. Does she get stuck in something and have to get pulled out? I haven't watched Speed 2, so I'm not sure yet. Me either. Will we? I kind of feel like I should like go see it because, okay, so here's the thing. When I was hired at one 800 dentist, I was doing my training and there was this story, kind of like legendary story.
我知道。对吧？是的。她一秒钟也没耽误，一秒钟都没耽误。现在哈里和杰克要顺着电梯滑下去，因为杰克意识到，我觉得那个炸弹客还在大楼里。是的。我觉得他在货运电梯里。是的。
There was an operator that worked there before me and he came in one day and he was like, suck it, eat it. I'm out of here because I got cast on Speed 2. I'm going to be on the boat. So kiss my ass. I quit. I don't know if it was that dramatic, but it was like he quit. He was going to go be on a boat for two months. He filmed for two months, lady. And then when the movie came out, all the operators were like, oh my God, we got to go see the guy, blah, blah. They went to the movie and I was like, how's the movie? And they were like, he's not in it. Oh my God. I was like, what? He had been cut out. There was like his shoulder. His shoulder was in it, like in the background for five seconds.
好吧，他们降落在货运电梯顶部，炸弹客听到声音，开始向上开枪，（你知道的）透过电梯顶部开枪。是的。杰夫·丹尼尔斯在现实生活中因为那个特技的弹片下巴缝了11针。是的。我开始变得有点痴迷，试图看看我能不能看到他的伤口，因为在EPK采访中，他的下巴上贴着一块精细的肉色绷带，因为他还在拍摄。
And I was like, oh my God. So I feel like I need to go see it. I need to go see it for a shoulder guy. Lady that so reminds me of when I got cast as the sixth member of the International Spice Girls. What? Remember? But it was really, it was like a front for a call girl ring. I told that story on the podcast. I know all of a sudden I thought you were cast in a movie and then you got cut out of
他下巴带着11针在拍戏。真正让我心烦意乱的是，安吉拉，真正真正让我受不了的是，因为你知道我对二次受伤这种事的看法。我们谈过这个。我们谈过。而且我们要一起去看《疾速追杀4》，我不知道你要怎么熬过去。我很担心。另外，《疾速追杀4》时长2小时49分钟。这是一个大项目。我们要去看IMAX版。
it. No, sorry. No, it was when I was going to be an International Spice Girl and I was explaining to people like, I don't know if I can come to your wedding. I might be on tour. You know, it's just like, I don't even know if I can come home for Thanksgiving this year. We're probably going to be rehearsing a lot. You know, I tell my boss, like I can be here for now, but eventually. Yes. This is what this guy did. He told everyone, like everyone, I'm going to be in speed too. Everyone in my life.
不，对不起。不，那是我以为我要成为国际辣妹组合成员的时候，我跟别人解释说，我不知道我能不能去参加你的婚礼。我可能在巡演。你知道的，就好像，我甚至不知道今年感恩节能不能回家。我们大概要进行大量排练。你知道的，我告诉我的老板，我目前可以待在这儿，但最终。是的。这就是这家伙干的事。他告诉了所有人，所有人，说我要去演《生死时速2》。我生活中的每一个人。
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And then everyone was like, hey, whatever happened with, you're like, oh, I don't want to talk about it. I was cut out. So they get all the hostages out just in time. I mean, Susan lost a shoe. She's lucky she didn't lose a foot.
对。对。对。然后每个人都问，嘿，后来怎么样了，你就会说，哦，我不想谈这个。我被剪掉了。所以他们及时救出了所有人质。我是说，苏珊丢了一只鞋。她没丢一只脚已经很走运了。
I know. Right? Yeah. She had not a second to spare, not a second to spare. And now Harry and Jack are going to lower themselves on the elevator because Jack realizes, I think the bomber is still in the building. Yeah. I think he's in a freight elevator. Yeah.
我知道。对吧？是的。她连一秒钟都没耽误，一秒钟都没耽误。现在哈里和杰克要顺着电梯下去，因为杰克意识到，我觉得炸弹客还在大楼里。是的。我觉得他在货运电梯里。是的。
Well, they land on top of the freight elevator and the bomber hears them and he starts shooting up, you know, through the top of the elevator. Yeah. Jeff Daniels got 11 stitches in his chin in real life from the shrapnel from that stunt. Yeah. And I became sort of obsessed with trying to see if I could see his injury because in the EPK interview, he's got like this elaborate nude bandage over his chin because he's still filming.
好吧，他们落在了货运电梯顶部，炸弹客听到动静，开始往上开枪，你知道的，透过电梯顶部。是的。杰夫·丹尼尔斯在现实生活中因为那个特技动作的弹片，下巴缝了11针。是的。我开始变得有点痴迷，试图看看能不能看到他的伤，因为在EPK采访中，他的下巴上贴着一块精致的肉色绷带，因为他还在拍戏。
He was filming with 11 stitches in his chin. And the thing that really upset me, Angela, the thing that really, really got me because you know how I feel about re-injuring injuries. We've talked about this. We have. And we're going to see John Wick 4 together and I don't know how you're going to get through it. I'm worried. Also, John Wick 4 is two hours and 49 minutes long. It's a commitment. We're seeing it in IMAX.
他带着下巴上的11针继续拍戏。安吉拉，真正让我难过的是，真正真正让我抓狂的是，因为你知道我对二次受伤这种事的看法。我们谈过这个。我们谈过。我们要一起去看《疾速追杀4》，我都不知道你要怎么看下来。我很担心。而且，《疾速追杀4》时长两小时四十九分钟。这真是一个巨大的承诺。我们要在IMAX厅看。
It's a commitment. Okay. Back to the subject at hand. After Jeff Daniels falls through the top of the elevator and then Dennis Hopper picks him up by his nose. Yeah. That was not in the script. No. Oh, I should say I found a script for speed. I don't know which iteration it is, but I found the script that picking him up by the nose is not in it.
这是一种承诺。好吧。回到正题。杰夫·丹尼尔斯从电梯顶部掉下去，然后丹尼斯·霍珀揪着他的鼻子把他提起来。是的。剧本里本来没有这个。没有。哦，我应该说我找到了《生死时速》的一个剧本。我不知道这是第几版，但我找到的剧本里没有揪鼻子这一段。
Okay. But at 21 minutes and 23 seconds, Dennis Hopper puts his fist underneath Jeff Daniels' chin and he is like jamming his fist into his chin and all I could think about was like, please tell me this was pre-stitches. Tell me they shot this before the shrapnel incident. I was very distracted by it. Dennis Hopper, aka Howard Payne, has shot up the roof of the elevator. Harry falls in, right? We've established that.
好吧。但在21分23秒时，丹尼斯·霍珀把拳头塞到杰夫·丹尼尔斯的下巴底下，他就像是在把拳头硬塞进对方的下巴里，我当时脑子里只想一件事：求求你告诉我这是缝针之前拍的。告诉我他们是在那个弹片事故之前拍的。我当时被这个弄得非常分心。丹尼斯·霍珀，也就是霍华德·佩恩，把电梯井顶给炸了。哈里掉了进来，对吧？我们已经确定了这一点。
Yes. With the fist to the chin, all of it. Yes. Yes. And now, I mean, Howard wants to smush, you know, Jack. I love it that you just called it smush. I mean, it's true. He wants to smush him and Jack is like, oh no, I'm going to get smushed. So he jumps
是的。又是顶到下巴，又是各种动作。是的。是的。现在，我是说，霍华德想要压扁，你知道的，杰克。我太喜欢你刚才管这叫“压扁”了。我是说，确实如此。他想压扁他，而杰克心想，哦不，我要被压扁了。所以他跳了
in to the elevator with Howard and Harry. And this is when we learned that Howard has been listening to them all the time because now he's saying pop quiz. Yep. He's going to trick everyone. Everyone is going to think that he's getting off on floor number three, but he's really going to P1. That's his escape route. He's got Harry by the chin. He's dragging him down the hallway and Harry says to Jack, shoot the hostage. And he does.
进电梯去找霍华德和哈里。这时候我们才知道，霍华德一直在监听他们，因为现在他说出了“突击测验”。没错。他要捉弄所有人。所有人都以为他会在三楼下车，但他实际上要去P1层。那是他的逃跑路线。他揪着哈里的下巴。他把哈里拖过走廊，哈里对杰克说：“开枪打人质。”然后他真的开了枪。
He shoots his friend in the leg. But listen, after he shoots him in the leg, Harry's like, fuck you, but he's just said shoot the hostage. Howard Payne is like, what the heck just happened here? But he makes his way into the parking lot and then he hits a button and they think he blows up and Jack goes, There's quite an explosion. There's quite an explosion. Jack goes flying through the air.
他朝他朋友的腿开了一枪。但是听着，在他朝他的腿开了一枪之后，哈里说了声“操你的”，但他刚才明明才说过开枪打人质。霍华德·佩恩当时就像是：这到底是怎么回事？但他还是走进了停车场，接着他按了一个按钮，他们以为他被炸飞了，杰克喊道：“轰！”有相当大的一场爆炸。有相当大的一场爆炸。杰克在空中飞了出去。
I watched many videos on how they did that stunt. So did I. I don't understand how you wouldn't get injured just from the controlled stunt doing of that stunt. I know. They put the guy on like some cables and they like yank him like eight feet. Yeah. Flying backwards. There were pads and whatnot. There were, but it still looked like your back might hurt later in the day.
我看了很多关于他们是怎么完成那个特技的视频。我也是。我不明白你怎么能在做那种受控特技时不受一点伤。我知道。他们把那个人绑在某种缆线上，然后像这样把他猛拽了八英尺远。是的。向后飞出去。那里有垫子什么的。确实有，但看起来你当天晚些时候背还是会疼。
My back would hurt later. My back. For much less than that. The stunt guy that did that was Brian Smurz, if I'm saying your last name right, Brian. And Brian was also the stunt driver of when the subway jumps. Yeah. Well, Jack and Harry are going to get medals for their bravery. They're going to go out and get super duper drunk.
我的背后来肯定会疼。我的背。为了远没有那么惊险的场面就会疼。做那个特技的特技演员是布莱恩·斯莫尔兹（Brian Smurz），如果我没把你的姓读错的话，布莱恩。布莱恩同时也是地铁跳跃那个镜头里的特技司机。是的。好吧，杰克和哈里因为他们的勇敢要获得勋章了。他们打算出去喝个酩酊大醉。
That's what you do. You get drunk. You dance kind of awkwardly at a bar. The next morning, Jack is going to get some coffee at what is clearly his favorite coffee house. He's a little hungover. He's going to run into Bob, who is a bus driver. It's our second Bob. I noted that. Yes. This Bob was played by John Cappadish, who is putting on gloves that are way too small for him.
这就是你该做的。你喝得酩酊大醉。你在酒吧里尴尬地跳着舞。第二天早上，杰克要在显然是他最喜欢的咖啡馆买杯咖啡宿醉未消。他会遇到鲍勃，一个公交车司机。这是我们的第二个鲍勃。我注意到了这一点。是的。这个鲍勃由约翰·卡帕迪什（John Cappadish）饰演，他当时正在戴着对他来说明显太小的手套。
I watched it several times. This is what you noticed. This is what you had to like rewatch was the glove moment. Watch it. Watch it. He's never going to get those gloves on his hands. I'm going to say this with love. I don't ever want to see this movie again. I loved it. Maybe you know what? I need a break. In six months, I'll rewatch it again and I'll go to this glove moment, but for right now, I can't do it. Okay. I understand. I get it. I get it. Bus driver with gloves that don't fit goes outside. He gets in his bus and it blows up.
我看了好几遍。这就是你注意到的。这就是你不得不倒回去重看的手套桥段。看啊。看啊。他根本不可能把那些手套戴到手上。我是怀着爱意说这话的：我再也不想看这部电影了。我太喜欢它了。也许，你知道吗？我需要休息一下。六个月后，我会再看一遍，我会看到这个手套桥段，但现在，我做不到。好吧。我理解。我懂。我懂。戴着不合手套的公交车司机走出去了。他上了公交车，然后车炸了。
This whole shot had to happen over Jack's shoulder. It was super hard to achieve the timing. They only had one bus to blow up, so the timing had to be perfect. Also, the bus that they blow up is not the bus that you see driving by moments before. It blows up. They did what is called a Texas switch. John said the real bus goes past Keanu and it takes a left turn, but you don't see it because you're on Keanu. Then when the camera sweeps back around, there's shell of a bus that had like a mannequin for a driver and it was being pulled by a truck. That was their bomb bus. That's the one that then you see blow up because you couldn't see the front
整个镜头必须在杰克肩膀上方拍摄。要把握好时机超级难。他们只有一辆公交车可以炸，所以时机必须完美。此外，他们炸毁的那公交车并不是你在几分钟前看到开过去的的那辆。它炸了。他们用了所谓的“德州大挪移”。约翰说真正的公交车从基努身边开过去，然后左转，但因为镜头对着基努，所以你看不到。然后当镜头重新扫回来时，那是一个公交车的空壳，里面有个假人司机，由一辆卡车拉着。那是他们的炸弹公交车。那就是你后来看到爆炸的那辆，因为你不能看到炸弹公交车的正面，所以你必须看到真公交车的正面。它左转，然后露出了炸弹公交车。假公交车。好吧。你猜怎么着？什么？那辆公交车在开始被拖走前停在那里有一会儿。好吧，因为他们不在片场，对吧？这实际上是在圣莫尼卡拍的。是的。这真的是在大街上拍的。他们以为已经封路了。一个女人突破了剧组的警戒线，
of the bomb bus, so you have to see the front of a real bus. It turns left and then it reveals bomb bus. Fakie bus. Okay. Guess what? What? That bus was sitting there for a second before it started being towed. Well, because they weren't on a set, right? This was actually in Santa Monica. Yes. This was really on the street. They thought they shut it down. A woman got past the production
跑上了炸弹公交车，以为自己错过了车。太可怕了。她看到了那个假人司机，感到非常困惑，而对讲机里，每个用对讲机的人都在喊：别炸公交车。千万别炸公交车。他们不得不重新拍摄这个镜头，把那个女人安全带离。那个女人差点在公交车上被炸死。太吓人了。我知道。
and ran onto bomb bus thinking she had missed her bus. That is terrifying. She saw the mannequin driver and was super confused and the radios, like everyone on the radios was like, don't blow up the bus. Do not blow up the bus. They had to start the shot over again and get that woman to safety. That woman almost got blown up on the bus. That is so scary. I know.
好吧，如果你把进度拉到28分零1秒，当有一个关于公交车的俯视高角度镜头时，你可以看到一辆红色的面包车，上面连着一个巨大的，我不知道，你管这叫什么？缆线。拉着公交车的缆线。你能看到牵引车吗？全都能看到。你在28分零1秒时全都能看到。扬（Jan）肯定会心碎的。扬在随片评论里非常坦诚地谈到了这件事。
Well, if you go to 28 minutes and one seconds, when there is a high camera angle shot of the bus, you can see a red van with a giant, like, I don't know, what do you call it? Cable. Cable pulling the bus. You can see the tow car? All of it. You can see all of it at 28 minutes, one seconds. Yon would be heartbroken. Yon shares about it very openly on the commentary.
哦，好吧。扬说，听着，我们到处都架了摄像机，拍到了一些穿帮。这是难免的。公用电话要响了。出于某种原因，杰克觉得在这辆被炸毁的公交车中间，自己有责任去接响个不停的公用电话。我只是觉得，如果我看到有什么东西炸了，然后公用电话突然开始响，我一定会觉得我最好去接一下。你会吗？
Oh, okay. Yon said, listen, we had cameras everywhere and we caught some things. It just is going to happen. The pay phone is going to ring. For some reason, Jack feels compelled to answer the ringing pay phone in the middle of this bombed bus. I just feel like if I saw something blow up and then all of a sudden the pay phones started ringing, I would think I better answer it. You would?
是的，百分之百。我觉得我会跑过去。我会注意到那里有个公用电话，因为这是智能手机、手机出现之前的年代。哦，别让我开始吐槽了，如果只是有人拿着一部iPhone去拍炸弹的照片，这部电影会变成什么样。哦，天哪。我待会儿还有一整堆牢骚要发呢。好吧，好吧。我们想法一致，但如果我突然看到公用电话在响，我会
Yes, 100%. I think I would run over. I would notice that there is a pay phone because this is the days before smartphones, before cell phones. Oh, don't get me started on how this movie would change if just someone had an iPhone to take a picture of a bomb. Oh, my gosh. I have a whole rant about it later. Okay, okay. We're on the same page, but if I suddenly saw the pay phone and it was ringing, I would
接起电话说，我得报警了，然后我会马上挂断。我甚至什么都不会说。我只会拿起来然后挂掉，接着打911。我才不会像这样说：喂？我会拿起来说：是你干的吗？你会的。是的。你会知道是那个炸弹狂魔在给你打电话。是的，我会的。
answer the phone and say, I have to call 911 and I would hang up immediately. I wouldn't even say anything. I would just pick it up and hang it up and then call 911. I wouldn't be like, hello? I would pick it up and say, did you do it? You would. Yes. You would know the bomber was calling you. Yes, I would.
好吧，电话那头正是我们的炸弹狂魔，他要告诉杰克，这可不是唯一一辆有炸弹的公交车。不。我要把整部电影的剧情全盘托出了。我觉得我们应该听听。我们应该听。我还要指出，伙计们，你们即将听到的整场戏其实是丹尼斯·霍珀拍摄的第一天。突击测验，神枪手。公交车上有个炸弹。一旦公交车时速达到50英里，炸弹
Well, on the other line is our bomber and he is going to tell Jack this is not the only bus with a bomb. No. I'm going to lay out the whole plot of the movie. I thought we should hear it. We should. And I want to point out, you guys, this whole scene that you're about to listen to was Dennis Hopper's first day of filming. Pop quiz, hot shot. There's a bomb on a bus. Once the bus goes 50 miles an hour, the bomb
就会被激活。如果时速降到50以下，它就会爆炸。你怎么办？你怎么办？我想知道那是哪辆公交车。你以为我会告诉你吗？是的。很好。这里有规矩，杰克，我要你把它记牢。任何人都不准下车。你试图让任何乘客下车。我就会引爆它。我必须在上午11点前拿到钱。我们在这么短时间内筹不到那么多钱。
is armed. If it drops below 50, it blows up. What do you do? What do you do? I'd want to know what bus it was. Do you think I'm going to tell you that? Yes. Very good. There are rules, Jack, and I want you to get this right. No one goes off the bus. You try to take any passengers off the bus. I will detonate it. I want my money by 11 AM. We can't pull that kind of money in time.
专心，杰克。你现在的核心是公交车。别试着打电话。电台坏了。现在，公交车的编号是2525。它正从威尼斯开往市中心。它现在在海洋公园大道的路口。然后他走了。他走了。伙计们，他在30分55秒时跳上了他的卡车。他把咖啡遗忘在吉普车顶上了。哦，天哪。他就顶着车顶上的咖啡开车走了。我觉得这非常现实。
Focus, Jack. Your concern is the bus. Don't try to call. The radio's down. Now, the number of the bus is 2525. It's running downtown from Venice. It's at the corner of Ocean Park. And he's off. He's off. He hops in his truck at 30 minutes, 55 seconds, you guys. He left his coffee on top of the Jeep. Oh, wow. He drives away with the coffee on top of his car. I thought this was very realistic.
我们现在要切到2525路公交车。它正在按站停靠，但你猜谁错过了车？安妮。安妮。她在后面追。她冲着司机萨姆大喊。萨姆由霍桑·詹姆斯（Hawthorne James）饰演。顺便问一句，她是一边跑一边抽烟吗？还拿着一杯咖啡。是的。在她上车之前，因为，你知道的，萨姆为她放慢了车速。他说：把烟熄了。
We are now going to cut to bus 2525. It's making it stops, but guess who missed the bus? Annie. Annie. She's running after. She's yelling at Sam, the driver. Sam played by Hawthorne James. By the way, is she running with a cigarette? And a coffee. Yeah. Before she gets on the bus, because, you know, Sam slows down for her. He says, put out the butt.
她说：好吧。然后她乱扔垃圾。我只是想指出这一点。我们今天绝不会让电影女主角去抽烟和乱扔垃圾。乱扔垃圾。而且还是在开场第一个镜头里。是的。她上了车。她找了个座位坐下，马上就有一个游客模样的男人过来跟她搭讪，这个演员是演过《春天不是读书天》的阿兰·鲁克（Alan Ruck）。但你知道吗？他的角色以前并不是个游客。在原剧本里他是个完全不同的角色。我找到了
And she goes, okay. And she litters. I just want to point that out. We would never let the heroine of our movie today throw smoke and litter. And litter. And the very first opening shot. Yes. She gets on the bus. She takes a seat and is immediately chatted up by a tourist played by Alan Ruck from Ferris Bueller's Day Off. But you know what? His character didn't used to be a tourist. He was a totally different character in the original script. And I found
一段他谈论这个的音频剪辑。我想也许我们可以听听看。也许我的角色原本应该是一个非常令人讨厌的、觉得自己高人一等的律师，他的宝马车正在修理厂，所以他只能窘迫地坐公交车。然后当我为此试镜时，扬·德·邦特（Jan de Bont）决定采取不同的方向，把我变成了这样一个，你知道的，土包子，一个笨手笨脚的游客。我觉得效果不错。我觉得这实际上是一个更好、更明智的选择。所以，你知道的，桑德拉·布洛克得想办法离他远点。因此她要假装她的座位上有口香糖。
an audio clip of him talking about it. And I thought maybe we could hear it. Maybe my character was supposed to be a really sort of loathsome, entitled attorney whose BMW was in the shop and he was stuck riding the bus. And then when I auditioned for it, Jan de Bont decided to go a different way with it and just turned me into this, you know, Yockel, this bumbling tourist. And I think it worked out. I think it was actually a better, a better choice. So you know, Sandra Bullock is going to have to get away from him. So she's going to pretend like there's gum on her seat.
哦，对。整个嚼口香糖的桥段是桑德拉·布洛克即兴发挥的。真的吗？是的。就在那一刻，他们正设法想出怎么让她脱身。于是她做出了这个口香糖的举动。我觉得效果棒极了。我觉得这非常聪明，因为这是一种非常讨人喜欢且得体的方式，能让她把这家伙打发走。所以她要站起来，然后她要坐到贝丝·格兰特（Beth Grant）旁边。海伦！
Oh yeah. The whole gum bit was improvised by Sandra Bullock. Really? Yeah. Just in the moment, they're trying to figure out how to get her away. And so she did this gum bit. I thought it worked great. I thought that was really smart because it was a very likeable kind way for her to like brush the sky off. So she's going to get up and then she's going to sit down next to Beth Grant. Helen!
当我们和贝丝谈到这个时，你们一定要听听她的采访。我们现在不重复细节了，但当时其实有另一个完全不同的剧本，就像阿兰·鲁克演的那种愤怒商人的版本。原剧本里有完全不同的设定。太有趣了。你们一定要听她的采访。她所有的幕后细节都太精彩了。所以我们现在把镜头扫过公交车，让我们大致了解一下所有的乘客都是谁。杰克在车流中狂飙，试图追上公交车。他要猛拍公交车的门，然后车窗裂了。
When we talked to Beth about this, you have to listen to her interview. We won't rehash it right now, but there was like this whole other script, like the one where Alan Ruck was like the angry businessman. There was this whole other thing in the original script. It's so interesting. You have to listen to her interview. All of her behind the scenes details are so wonderful. So we kind of pan around the bus now and we get a sense of who all of our passengers are. Jack is racing through traffic trying to catch up to the bus. He's going to bang on the bus door and the window cracks.
是的。那不是计划好的。什么？是的。事情就那么发生了。然后这在某种程度上成了一个连贯性问题，因为有时你会看到一辆车门裂开的公交车。有时它又没有裂。裂了，没裂，裂了，裂了，没裂。哇。好吧，当公交车开走、把杰克留在路边时，公交车的时速当时其实还没有达到50英里。所以炸弹还没有被激活，这在某种程度上造成了一个巨大的情节漏洞。在一个整体而言还算严密的剧本里。珍妮特·马斯林（Janet Maslin）在她的
Yeah. That was not planned. What? Yeah. That just happened. And then it kind of became a continuity thing because sometimes you see a bus with the door that's cracked. Sometimes it doesn't have a crack. Crack no crack crack crack no crack. Wow. Well, as the bus is driving away, leaving Jack on the side of the road, the bus is not yet going 50 miles an hour. So the bomb has not been engaged and this sort of creates a big plot hole. In another wise, pretty tight script. It was pointed out in Janet Maslin's
评论中指出了这一点。是的，珍妮特。你认识珍妮特吗？我是说，我不认识她，但她的评论太棒了。是的。她在《纽约时报》上的评论里说，此时公交车的时速只有15或20英里左右。他手里有枪。他为什么不直接开枪打爆轮胎，这样炸弹就永远不会被激活了呢？嗯。
review. Yes, Janet. Did you know Janet? I mean, I don't know her, but her review is amazing. Yes. Her New York Times review, she said, at this point, the bus is only going about 15 or 20 miles an hour. He has a gun. Why doesn't he shoot out the tires so that the bomb is never engaged? Hmm.
好吧，这篇评论一直困扰着编剧格雷厄姆·约斯特（Graham Yost），20年后他还在讨论这件事，并表示：是的，他真希望自己当时想到了这一点。他说，如果让他重来一次，他会让杰克掏出枪，然后让捷豹汽车的司机故意撞击杰克，以为杰克是个坏人，接着杰克的枪就会飞出去，然后杰克就会上那个家伙的车，这将是解决这个问题的完美方式。对。当然，那样的话，杰克就没有枪去指着那个掏枪对准他的乘客了。
Well, this review has haunted screenwriter, Graham Yost, who 20 years later was still discussing this and said, yes, he wished he had thought of this. He said, if he had to do it all over again, he would have Jack pull out his gun and then he would have the driver of the Jaguar purposely bump Jack, thinking that Jack was like a bad guy and then Jack's gun would go flying and then Jack would get in the guy's car and that that would be like a perfect way to solve this problem. Right. Of course, then Jack wouldn't have had a gun to pull on the passenger who pulls a gun
哦，天哪。那他就不会有那个对峙僵局了。我不知道该怎么跟格雷厄姆说这件事，因为他当时真的很兴奋自己能修补这个情节漏洞。他需要他的枪。否则，那个拿枪的乘客就会把公交车给拦停了。这真是个好点子。
on him. Oh my gosh. Then he wouldn't have had a still mate. I don't know how to tell Graham that because he was really excited to have fixed this plot hole. He needed his gun. Otherwise, the passenger with the gun would have had the bus pulled over. This is a really good point.
我只是随便说说。嗯-hmm。好吧，杰克现在要拦下一辆开着捷豹汽车、车牌号是“调音师”（tune man）的家伙。是的。他由格伦·普拉默（Glenn Plummer）饰演。他甚至还回归出演了《生死时速2》。真的吗？是的。
Just saying. Mm-hmm. Well, Jack is now going to flag down a guy driving a Jaguar licensed plate tune man. Yes. He was played by Glenn Plummer. He also comes back for speed too. Really? Yes.
他饰演莫里斯。哇。嗯-hmm。杰克会说：听着，我需要，基本上他需要借用对方的车。是的。让开。嗯-hmm。就在公交车时速刚好达到50英里时，他追上了公交车。
He plays Maurice. Wow. Mm-hmm. Jack is going to say, listen, I need, you know, basically he needs to use his car. Yeah. Get over. Mm-hmm. He's going to catch up with the bus right as it hits 50 miles an hour.
运气太背了。运气太背了。真该死。炸弹被激活了，现在杰克必须想办法告诉萨姆，他必须把车速保持在50英里。是的。他们设法通过，我猜，把字写在纸上然后隔着车门大喊来传达这一切。但现在基努需要上车了。
The worst luck. The worst luck. Darn it. The bomb is activated and now Jack has to somehow tell Sam he's got to keep it at 50. Yes. They managed to communicate all this with, I guess, writing it on a piece of paper and then screaming it in through the door. But Keanu now, he needs to get on the bus.
好吧。他必须上车。是的。他上车的这个特技，是基努自己完成的。他真的是从一辆车上跳到公交车上。当时车速是每小时50英里。两辆车必须保持相同的速度。导演本来不想让他这么做，但基努和特技团队一起训练，他真的做到了。
Okay. He has to get on. Yeah. This stunt of him getting on the bus, Keanu did this himself. He really jumped from a car onto a bus. They were going 50 miles an hour. The two vehicles had to stay the same speed. The director didn't want him to do it, but Keanu trained with the stunt team and he did.
他真的把这件高难度的事给干成了。这里是特技协调员加里·海姆斯（Gary Himes）在谈论和基努一起完成这个特技的经历。早期浮现在我脑海中的情况之一，就是他从捷豹汽车转移到公交车上的时候。我们讨论过这件事。我们反复商量过。他对此显得非常自在。我接着在公交车下方搭建了一个平台，这样万一他真的失手了，他也不会
He did the dang thing. Here is the stunt coordinator, Gary Himes, discussing doing this stunt with Keanu. One of the situations that comes to mind early on was when he's transferring from the jaguar to the bus. We had talked about it. We had talked it through. He seemed very comfortable with it. I went ahead and built a platform under the bus, so indeed if he did miss, he wasn't going
直接摔在地上，因为我们在高速公路上以每小时50英里的速度狂奔。一旦我们到了那里，第一次准备拍摄时，他对当时的情况还是稍微有点不太自在。我喊了停，然后我们退回去了。我们讨论了做一些小改动，没什么大不了的，然后他又做了一次。他完成得太好了，以至于我们想再拍一个镜头，我们实际上把汽车和公交车的间距拉得更远了，而他还是上了，我是说那真是一个极棒的镜头。好吧，我这里还有一个关于《办公室》和《生死时速》的联动要告诉你。
to hit the ground because we're running 50 miles an hour down the freeway. Once we got out there and the first time we went to shoot it, he was just a little bit uncomfortable with the situation. I cut the shot and we went back. We talked about making a couple little changes, nothing major, and he did it. He did it so well that we wanted to get one more take of that, and we actually moved the car and the bus further apart, and he went for it, and I mean it was a great shot. Well I have a second The Office Speed Crossover for you.
你是说除了贝丝·格兰特之外？是的。加里·海姆斯曾参与过《宿醉3》的工作。和艾德·赫尔姆斯合作过。好吧，原来如此。我想让你们知道，在39分55秒时，正当基努准备跳上公交车时，有一个从背后拍摄的镜头，风，你可以看出他们开得有多快，因为风掀起了他衬衫的背面，你能看到他的麦克风包。
You mean besides Beth Grant? Yes. Gary Himes worked on the hangover part three. With Ed Helms. Well, there you go. I want you to know at 39 minutes and 55 seconds, as Keanu is getting ready to jump onto the bus, there's a shot from behind and the wind, you can tell how fast they're going because the wind whips up the back of his shirt and you can see his mic pack.
好吧，我觉得我们该休息一下了，因为等我们回来时，杰克已经在车上了，伙计们。他在公交车上，而且发生了好多事。我们回来了。我们在车上，伙计们。杰克在车上，紧接着，更多的混乱上演了。是的。一个男人拿枪指着杰克，因为他以为杰克是冲着他登车的。这个男人由丹尼尔·比利亚雷亚尔（Daniel Villarreal）饰演，杰克当时就说：我不是来找你的。
Well, I think we should take a break because when we come back, Jack is on the bus, y'all. He's on the bus and a lot happens. We're back. We're on the bus, you guys. Jack is on the bus and right away, there's even more mayhem. Yes. A man pulls a gun on Jack because he thinks that Jack has boarded the bus for him. The man was played by Daniel Villarreal and yeah, Jack is like, I'm not here for you.
他有一些很棒的台词。他说：我们没事。我们没事。然后他把枪收了起来。那把他在对峙时必须用到的枪，我只是顺便提一句。不，这倒也是真的。他后来还要用到这把枪。但车上的另一个乘客看到了一个机会。
He has some great dialogue. He's like, we're good. We're good. And he's going to put his gun away. His gun that he needed to have for the standoff, just saying. No, this is true. He's going to use this gun later too. But one of the other passengers on the bus is going to see an opportunity.
他要把那个拿枪的家伙扑倒。枪走火了。打中了公交车司机。萨姆！是的。打中了肩膀。他就像这样倒在方向盘上，突然之间，安妮不得不顶上去开车。
He's going to tackle the guy with the gun. The gun's going to go off. It's going to shoot the bus driver. Sam! Yes. In the shoulder. He's like, falls over the steering wheel and all of a sudden, Annie's got to step in to drive.
是的。这时候杰克要向所有人宣布公交车上有炸弹这个消息，因为安妮开始减速了。显然，她需要减速。萨姆中枪了。而杰克却说：不，不，这辆公交车上有炸弹。所有人都惊呼：哇。什么？
Yes. This is when Jack is going to tell everyone the news that there's a bomb on the bus because Annie's starting to slow down. Obviously, she needs to slow down. Sam has been shot. And he's like, no, no, there's a bomb on this bus. Everyone's like, whoa. What?
我的天。什么？所以我想说的是，在剧本的第一版中，安妮这个角色是一名急救人员。这主要是为了合理解释她为什么能在车流中飞快地驾驶公交车。然后在第二版迭代中，就像你说的，她变成了一个滑稽的驾校教练。最后他们敲定的设定是：她因为超速而被吊销了驾照。好吧，在删减片段中，她和海伦分享了更多内容。
My gosh. What? So I wanted to say that in the first version of the script, the character of Annie was a paramedic. And this was to justify the fact that she could drive a bus really quickly through traffic. Then in the second iteration, like you said, she became this comedic driver's ed teacher. Finally they settled with just that she had her license revoked for speeding. Well in deleted scenes, there was more that she shares with Helen.
真的吗？是的。她告诉海伦她是一名平面设计师，但目前在一家快餐店打工。哦。嗯-hmm。正如你们所知，桑德拉·布洛克接受了真正的公交车驾驶培训，并在电影开拍前通过了公交车驾照考试。然而，她实际上从来没有开过这辆公交车。
Really? Yeah. She tells Helen she's a graphic designer, but currently working at like a fast food restaurant. Oh. Mm-hmm. And as you know, Sandra Bullock trained to actually be able to drive a bus and she passed a bus driving test before the movie started shooting. However, she is never driving the bus.
一次都没有。她并不是真的在开公交车。在随片评论中，他们确实说过，当他们在机场、拥有那片开阔的大片空地时，他们让她开了一两次，你知道的。就开了一秒钟。是的。而且她确实撞到了几个路标。天哪。
Not one time. She's not really driving the bus. In the commentary, they did say when they were at the airport and they had all that big open space, they let her drive just, you know, one or two. For a second. Yeah. And she did hit a few cones. Oh dear.
是的。好吧，真正开这辆公交车的人是特技司机吉尔·库姆斯（Gil Combs）。他被藏在这辆公交车的各个地方。很多时候，他就趴在公交车顶上。是的。他们搭建了一个这样的装置。就像一个他坐在里面的笼子。我是说，说是笼子都算抬举了。
Yeah. Well, the person who was actually driving the bus was stunt driver Gil Combs. And he was hidden all over this bus. A lot of the time, he was on top of the bus. Yeah. They built like this rig. Like a cage that he sat in. I mean, cage is generous.
那里有几根栏杆，你能看到他拿着一个操作踏板和一个大方向盘待在上面。还戴着头盔。戴着头盔，但很矮。我知道。我只是，我看着他心想，我是说，如果，如果你从那辆公交车顶上掉下来，你腿上的皮绝对会被全刮掉。好吧，当时是九月份。
There were a couple of bars and you can see him up there with an operating pedal and a big steering wheel. And a helmet. A helmet, but short. I know. I just, I was looking at him and I was like, I mean, what, you're, if you fall off the top of that bus, the skin on your legs is going to be shredded. Well, it was September.
他做出了选择。我想也是。他们还把他安排在公交车尾部。有时把他低低地安排在其中一个座位上。他基本上就像是坐在地板上，他们说他们不得不给他一个小巧的迷你方向盘。为了根据摄像机角度隐藏他，他们把他塞到了各种地方。好吧，杰克要给哈里打电话，他们决定他应该去查看一下
He made a choice. I guess so. They also put him at the back of the bus. They put him low in one of the seats sometimes. He was like sitting basically on the floor and they said they had to give him a little tiny mini wheel. They put him all over the place to hide him depending on the camera angle. Well, Jack is going to get on the phone with Harry and they decide he should check out
这个炸弹。当他以某种方式“亲眼看到”这个炸弹。对。是的。所以他们会记起这里有一个检修面板，然后他把头伸下去，看着这个炸弹。这时候我说过，如果当时有人有一部iPhone，那就真的太好了。我也这么觉得。
this bomb. When he get somehow like eyes on this bomb. Right. Yeah. So they're going to remember that there's like this access panel and he's going to stick his head down and he's going to look at this bomb. This is when I said it really would have been nice if someone had an iPhone. I thought so too.
他正在和游客以及哈里玩这种传话游戏，但如果他当时能直接开个FaceTime，然后说：哈里，情况就是这样。你有什么看法？好吧，正当这一切发生时，公交车在减速。前面有些交通堵塞。安妮正试图引起杰克的注意。她喊道：喂，喂。
He's playing this game of telephone with the tourist and Harry and him, but instead he could have just like put it on a FaceTime and been like, Harry, this is what it was like. What are your thoughts? Well, while all of this is going on, the bus is slowing down. There's some traffic. Annie is trying to get Jack's attention. She's like, hello, hello.
她抓起那个小话筒一样的东西大喊：嘿，警官，是在里面还是外面，在里面还是外面？那是桑德拉·布洛克的点子，抓起那个小话筒。我真的很喜欢那个。我知道。杰克说：下高速，下！她接下来撞到了一系列基本上什么都有的东西。一些路标、水桶，贝丝跟我们谈起过这个。所以大家一定要去听她的采访。
She grabs a little microphone thing and screams, hey, officer, on or off, on or off. That was Sandra Bullock's idea, grabbing that little microphone. I really liked that. I know. Jack says, get off the freeway off. She's going to run into a series of pretty much anything. Some cones, water barrels, Beth talked about this with us. So you guys be sure and listen to her interview.
然后她撞上了一辆婴儿车，一个正在过马路的女人。好吧。我猜他们觉得，当他们对电影进行试映时，真正卖座（让观众信服）的一个点是：那不是一个推着婴儿车的女人。那是两个正在说话的女人。所以你会觉得那个婴儿车里可能真的有个婴儿。是的。所以这是福克斯在开发阶段提出的一条意见。
And then she's going to run into a baby carriage, a woman crossing the street. Okay. I guess one of the things they felt like when they tested the movie that really sold this moment is that it's not one woman with a carriage. It's two women talking. So you're thinking maybe there's a baby in that baby carriage. Yeah. So this was a note from Fox during the development period.
编剧说，当时的意见大约是：如果他们差点撞到婴儿车之类的东西，会不会大大提升这里的紧张感。而编剧当时的想法大约是：你知道吗，这感觉像是在作弊，就像电影里那种汽车追逐时汽车冲过一个水果摊的情节，那种完全没有任何危险感的东西。所以他说他记起自己在纽约市看到过一个家伙推着一辆装满易拉罐的手推车过马路。他说：如果婴儿车里装的是易拉罐呢？
The writer said the note was like, what if they like almost hit a baby carriage or something that would really up the tension here. And the writer was kind of like, you know what, it feels like a cheat, you know, like in movies when there's a car chase and then the car runs through a fruit stand, like something just like not at all dangerous. So he said he remembered that he saw a guy in New York City walking across the street with a shopping cart full of cans. He's like, what if there were cans in the baby carriage?
然后扬提出了使用那种非常经典的英式婴儿车的想法。好吧，我觉得桑德拉·布洛克的反应就像我会做的那样。我会觉得：天哪，我撞到婴儿车了。是的。我得说，我觉得杰克恢复得太快了。我觉得杰克就像是，他们撞了婴儿车，然后他就说：哦不，我们没事。我就想：什么？
And then it was Jan's idea to use like one of those really classic English prams. Well, I felt like Sandra Bullock's reaction was like what I would have done. I'd be like, oh my God, I got a baby. Yeah. I will say, I felt like Jack got over it very quickly. I feel like Jack was like, like they hit the baby stroller and then he's like, oh no, we're good. I'm like, what?
这也太快了吧。好吧，这还不是唯一的戏剧性场面。为了开回高速公路，前面即将迎来一个非常急的右转。麦克设法找来了所有这些警用直升机和警察护送，这样我们才能把车速保持在每小时50英里。你猜怎么着？他要带他们去105号高速公路正在施工的路段。他们将拥有对那里的完全控制权。
That was so quick. Well, this isn't the only drama. There's going to be a really ugly right turn coming up in order to get back onto the freeway. Mack has managed to get like all these police helicopters and a police escort so we can keep the bus at 50 miles an hour. And guess what? He's going to take them to this section of the 105 freeway that is under construction. They're going to have complete control of it.
那里将完全没有车辆。这太棒了。但为了到达那里，你必须来一个超级急的右转，一个90度的转弯。哦，天哪。正当这一切发生时，哈里开始拼凑出霍华德·佩恩究竟可能是谁。是的。展现了一些简直不可思议的“思考演技”。
There's going to be like no traffic. It's going to be great. But in order to get there, you're going to have to take a super hard right, a 90 degree turn. Oh my God. While all this is happening, Harry is starting to piece together who Howard Payne might be. Yeah. Doing some just incredible think acting.
是的。他有一个眼神。他有一个主意。他看了一眼电脑。他看了一眼公告栏。嗯-hmm。就是一些小眼神。是的。
Yeah. He's got a look. He's got an idea. He's got a look at a computer. He's got a look at a bulletin board. Mm-hmm. That's a little glances. Yeah.
这叫做“眼神演技”。我是说，我当时看得入迷极了，我真不是开玩笑。我知道。所以有个情况。105号高速公路在他们拍这部电影时实际上正在施工。他们获得了在空旷的高速公路上拍摄的许可。但他们每天都会收到一份报告，说明他们被允许在高速公路的哪个路段拍摄。
This is called glance acting. I mean, I was riveted and I'm not even kidding. I know. So here's something. The 105 freeway was actually under construction while they were filming this movie. They got permission to shoot on the empty freeway. But every day they would get like a report over which section of the freeway they were allowed to shoot.
所以他们不得不四处挪动，因为那里在进行实地建设。建设。是的。有时他们赶到现场，发现上面连车道线都没画。他们不得不先在高速公路上画好线，然后才能开始拍摄。好吧，我得跟你们分享一下扬说的话。我是说，我叫他扬，好像我们是挚友一样，但我听了他讲了整整两个小时，伙计们。
So they were having to move around because they were actively building it. Building. Yeah. Sometimes they would show up and there would be no lines painted. And they would have to paint lines on the freeway before they could start shooting. Okay, I have to share with you what Yon said. I mean, I'm calling him Yon like we're best friends, but I listened to him talk for two hours, you guys.
所以他说，拥有这么一条巨大空旷的高速公路既有真正的好处，也有坏处。他们太幸运了，对吧，能得到这个。但他说，在整个拍摄期间，你在整条巨大高速公路两侧看到的每一辆车，全都是剧组的道具车。因为这不是一条通车的高速公路，上面没有任何车辆。他们必须为汽车和司机进行选角。他们必须进行编排，想象一下要编排数百辆车，它们在每次拍摄后都必须返回起点，
So he said that there were some real pros and cons to having this whole big open freeway. They were so lucky, right, that they got this. But he said every car you see on both sides of this big freeway for the whole entire shoot were production cars. Because it wasn't an active freeway, there were no cars on it. They had to cast cars and drivers. They had to choreograph it and imagine choreographing hundreds of cars that have to go back to a starting point.
这需要花费大量时间。他说这是一场后勤噩梦。他说他们每天都会以一个会议开始，他和特技协调员加里。他们有一个装满玩具小汽车的小包。我在幕后视频里看到过这个。他们会趴在地上用粉笔画出高速公路。然后他们有小汽车。他们有一辆公交车。
After each take, it took a lot of time. He said it was a logistical nightmare. He said that they would start the day with a meeting, him and the stunt coordinator, Gary. They had a little bag of toy cars. I saw this in the behind the scenes videos. They'd get on the ground and draw the freeway with chalk. And then they had little cars. They had a bus.
他们有一架直升机，所有人都会围过来，规划他们当天要做的事情。他们说，这是从视觉上让所有人达成共识的最佳方法。他说的另一件事是，他们只有六周时间。这条高速公路将在六周后完工，所以这就是他们能在上面使用的所有时间。而且那是用来拍所有镜头的。那是用来拍所有关于“调音师”的内容的。
They had a helicopter and they would all gather around and they would plot out what they were doing for the day. They said it was the best way visually to get everyone on the same page. The other thing he said is they had six weeks. The freeway was going to be completed in six weeks, so that's all the time they had on it. And that was to shoot everything. That was to shoot all the Toon Man stuff.
这也是用来拍这一部分的。因此，为了让电影摄制组能够一直使用这条高速公路直到它基本开通，有一份他们必须承诺完成的事情清单。例如，他们必须像你刚才说的那样，画好一些车道线。高速公路标线。他们必须竖起一些标牌。导演说，他们觉得自己在拍电影之余，简直成了筑路工人。
That was to shoot this part as well. So for the film crew to be able to use the freeway right up to basically the opening of it, there was a list of things that they had to promise to be done. For example, they had to paint some of the lines like you were talking about. Freeway lines. They had to put up some signage. The director said they felt like they had become road builders in addition to making a movie.
而且在他们杀青五天后，高速公路就正式开通了。哦，天哪，这也太疯狂了。我知道。好吧，听着，萨姆情况很不妙。没有。他们要把他弄下公交车。而霍华德会同意。他会说你可以把司机卸载下来，但仅此而已。
And five days after they wrapped filming, the freeway opened. Oh my gosh, that is insane. I know. Well, listen, Sam is not doing well. No. He's going to get him off the bus. And Howard is going to agree. He's going to say you can unload the driver, but that's it.
所以特警队的车会开到公交车旁边，他们会平行行驶，然后把公交车司机转移下来。是的，转移到这辆巨大的平板卡车上。但就在这时，贝丝·格兰特决定她可能也想下车。海伦受够了。我知道她坐公交车是因为这比开车压力小。所以这个女人本来就很焦虑。而警察们还在鼓励她。
And so the SWAT team is going to pull up next to the bus, and they're going to be driving parallel, and they're going to unload the bus driver. Yeah, onto this big flatbed truck. But that is when Beth Grant is going to decide she might want to get off the bus too. Helen's had it. I know she was taking the bus because it was less stressful than driving. So the woman's already anxious. And the police officers are, they're encouraging her.
他们说：来吧，女士，来吧，把手给我。难道他们不知道规矩吗？他们刚才没听见吗？好吧，你猜谁看到了这一幕？霍华德。他看到了这一幕发生，然后他按下了他的小按钮。公交车的阶梯瞬间爆炸，海伦重重地摔在了车轮底下。她死了。
They're like, come on, lady, come on, give me your hand. Don't they know the rules? Were they not listening? Well, guess who's going to see this, Howard. He's going to see this happen, and he's going to press his little button. And the steps to the bus are going to explode, and Helen is going to go crashing down under the wheels. She's dead.
她死了。在影片进行到1小时零2分钟时，观众们会潸然泪下。在他们拍摄这个戏剧性的哭泣场景的全程中。你可以在公交车窗外看到载着特警队的那个平板车。那些背景演员们，真得说说他们的背景工作。他们必须在所有这些镜头里陪着公交车一路行驶，因为你能从窗户看到他们。当我看着这一幕时，我脑子里想的全都是：有没有虫子撞到谁？
She's dead. And the public is going to burst into tears at one hour and two minutes. The whole time, they were doing this dramatic crying scene. You can see outside the bus window that flatbed with the SWAT team. Those guys talk about background work. They had to ride alongside the bus for all these scenes because you could see them out the window. As I watched this, all I could think about was like, did a bug hit anyone?
虫子当然撞到人了。我是说，我确信虫子一直在撞他们。当你做背景演员不知道多少天，站在平板卡车上，是站着，甚至不是坐着，风以大约每小时50英里的速度吹在你身上，然后你晚上去把头枕在枕头上时，会发生什么？你的皮肤被风吹裂了，可能还有虫子撞过你。你一定能感觉得到。你被晒伤了，也许你想嘘嘘，但你不能。
Of course a bug hit people. I mean, I'm sure bugs were hitting them. What happens after you've done how many days of background work, standing on a flatbed, standing, not even sitting, with the wind hitting you at like 50 miles an hour, and you go to lay your head down on the pillow at night? Your wind chafed, a bug's probably hit you. You have to be feeling that. Your sunburn, maybe you had to pee, but you couldn't.
你身上还穿着装备。我是说，太残酷了。漫长的一天。好吧，安妮和杰克现在彻底卷入其中了。他们两个，我是说，她在开车。他就像副驾驶。我一直很好奇为什么他从来不开车，但他需要随时准备用对讲机通话。好吧，好吧，好吧。
You have gear on. I mean, brutal. It's a long day. Well, Annie and Jack are in it now. The two of them, I mean, she's driving. He's like co-pilot. I always wondered why he never drove, but he needs to be available to talk on the radio. Okay, okay.
他必须和在平板车上的人通话。好吧，行，好吧，好吧。而且，他信任她。这很好，但也许她想休息一下，我只是随便说说。不过话说回来，安妮对杰克说：嘿，你能把一下方向盘吗？因为她要把那个毛衣开衫之类的东西脱掉——一个剧情关键点，因为现在你会看到那件小亚利桑那。嗯-hmm。
He has to talk to the people on the flatbed. Fine, okay, fine, fine. And also, he trusts her. That's great, but maybe she wanted a break, I'm just saying. But anyway, Annie says to Jack, hey, can you take the wheel, because she's going to take off that sweater cardigan thing, plot point, because now you're going to see the little Arizona. Mm-hmm.
那只小野猫。野猫。好吧，你和我看了很多关于演员的采访，看他们如何看待彼此的合作以及各自角色的背景。网上有海量的这类内容。但珍娜，我想花点时间问你，有没有人把你和某个季节、某个一年中的时间做过对比？没有。
The little wildcat. Wildcat. Well, you and I watched a bunch of interviews of the cast and what they thought of working with each other and their character backgrounds. There's tons out there. But Jenna, I wanted to take a moment and ask you if anyone has ever compared you to a season, to a time of the year. No.
我希望有。没有，我也是。好吧，我觉得你应该听听这个，因为如果我们还不够深爱基努的话，准备好吧。她是一位美丽的女士，非常美丽，富有奉献精神，而且我不知道。她身上有一种美好、如此美妙的能量和生命力，无论她走到哪里，她总是全力付出，并希望事物能如春天般美好。这是他在谈论桑德拉·布洛克。他把她形容为春天。
I wish. No, me either. Well, I think you should hear this, because if we couldn't love Keanu more, get ready. She's a beautiful lady, very beautiful, giving, and I don't know. She has a nice, such a wonderful energy about her and life, and she's just wherever she goes and she really gives and wants things to be springtime. This is him talking about Sandra Bullock. He describes her as springtime.
我不知道我能不能放下这个。我喜欢他说话时那种从容不迫的态度和心思。我觉得他的声音很让人平静。他听起来就像一次巨大的呼气。嗯-hmm。你知道，我们所有人都承受着太多的压力，而他是如此放松，就像春天。然后他接着说她是一个伟大的演员，并称赞了她在电影中的表现。接着她跑过去给了他一个熊抱。
I don't know if I'm ever going to get over it. I love the time and care he takes when speaking. He sounds calming to me. He sounds just like a giant exhale. Mm-hmm. You know, we're all holding so much tension, and then he is so relaxed, springtime. And then he goes on to say she's a great actress and compliments her work on the movie. And then she runs in and bear hugs him.
他根本没看到她过来，然后他们来了个巨大的熊抱。等等，我看到了那一幕，然后他脸红了。他脸红了。他夸奖了她的衬衫，接着她跑开了，而他则面红耳赤地看着摄像机说：啦啦。好吧。好吧，听听我们。听听我们。
He doesn't see her coming, and they do this giant bear hug. Wait, I saw that, and then he blushes. He blushes. He compliments her blouse, and then she runs off, and he just looks at the camera completely flushed and says, voila. Okay. Okay, listen to us. Listen to us.
我们神魂颠倒了。我们神魂颠倒了。还有一个问题。什么？又来一个？对。别放松。
We're swooning. We're swooning. There's another problem. What? Another one? Yeah. No. Don't relax.
在这部电影里？嗯-hmm。高速公路上有一段是断开的。哦，操。他们，我猜他们修路不是从一头往前推进，而是从两头往中间汇合，结果这个匝道有一大截根本没有完工。我对这个匝道非常熟悉，因为我有一次在这条匝道上开车时经历了一次全面的恐慌发作。
In this movie? Mm-hmm. There is a section of the freeway that is missing. Oh, crap. They, I guess they were building it not from one side forward, but from two sides to meet in the middle, and there's a huge part of this ramp that is not completed. I know this ramp very well because I had a full panic attack driving on this ramp one year.
这对我来说完全是突如其来的。太诡异了。我当时正开车去机场。各位，这就是去机场必经的路。我开始开上这个匝道，然后我出现了恐慌发作的所有生理症状。我的心跳开始加速。这只是你自己的原因，不是因为电影吧？不是因为电影。
It came out of the blue for me. It is so bizarre. I was driving to the airport. This is the road you take to the airport, everybody. And I started driving up this ramp, and I got all the physical symptoms of a panic attack. My heart started racing. Now was this just on your own, not from the movie? Not from the movie.
只有你。这只是我经历的一个时刻。这个匝道在空中非常高。我想让你们知道，在现实生活中，你开得非常高。感觉就像你要开进云端一样。我第一次开它的时候，我不知道自己怎么了。我开上匝道，然后开始心悸。我的手心在出汗。
Just you. This was just a moment that I had. This ramp is very high up in the air. I want you to know in real life, you go up very high. It feels like you're going to go into the clouds. And the first time I drove it, I don't know what happened to me. I went up the ramp and I started getting heart palpitations. My palms were sweating.
我开始呼吸急促。我正处于恐慌发作的水深火热之中。我用尽了所有的抗焦虑训练来让自己平静下来。我在匝道另一头开了下来，然后症状开始消散，但一旦我下了匝道，我真的不得不把车停在路边，做几个深呼吸。这就是我和这个匝道的私人故事。你把车停在匝道边上了吗？不，天哪，没有。
I started getting shortness of breath. I was in the throes of a panic attack. I used all of my anxiety training to talk myself down. I got off on the other side of the ramp, and then it started to disperse, but like I had to actually stop the car and take some deep breaths once I was off the ramp. Just personal story about me and this ramp. Did you pull over on the side of the ramp? No, my God, no.
我得把车开下匝道。不，因为千万别那样做。永远不要那样做。千万别那样做。不。我是说我下了匝道之后。一旦你下了匝道。我从一个出口下来了。
I had to get down the ramp. No, because don't do that. Don't ever do that. Never do that. No. I'm saying once I got off the ramp. Once you were off the ramp. I took an exit.
我得下匝道。不，因为别那样。千万别那样。别那样。不。我是说我下了匝道之后。等你下了匝道之后。我找了个出口。
And then you took a moment. I remember it like it was yesterday. It was years and years and years ago, but anyway, this is a scary ramp, okay? It's a scary ramp. That's what you guys- Even when it's completed. This is what you need to know. So something you should know is that there was no road missing in real life. And in fact, at one hour and five minutes and 24 seconds in the establishing shot in
然后你花了一点时间。我记得那就像昨天一样。那是很多很多年以前的事了，不过话说回来，这是一个很吓人的匝道，对吧？这是一个很吓人的匝道。这就是你们——即使它已经建成了。这是你需要了解的。所以你该知道的是，现实中并没有哪段路是不见了的。事实上，在电影开头的一个建立镜头里，
the movie of this missing piece of road, they digitally removed the road, but you can still see the shadow from where the road would have been underneath. So they forgot to digitally remove the shadow. Oh, gosh. Look at me. I'm like, oh, gosh. Like, I know anything about, like, uh, digital, whatever. Yes.
时间是1小时5分24秒，他们用数字技术抹去了这截缺失的道路，但你依然能看到底下本该有路时的阴影。所以他们忘了用数字技术把阴影也抹掉。哦，天哪。看看我。我就像，哦，天哪。好像我懂什么数字技术之类的东西似的。是的。
Like I'm like the shock, the horror, the shadow. The writer said that the bus jump was not in the earlier drafts of the movie. He said this was Jan's idea, that Jan said, at a certain point in the movie, I want to hit a metaphorical wall. I want there to be a point where it looks like it's game over and there is no way they can get out of it. He goes on to say that he thought at this point in the movie, the bus needed a really big challenge and every day they were looking at parts of an unfinished freeway.
就像我很震惊、很惊恐，那个阴影。编剧说，巴士飞跃的桥段并不在电影早期的剧本中。他说这是简的主意，简在电影的某个时刻说过，我想撞上一面隐喻的墙。我希望有一个时刻，看起来就像游戏结束了，他们绝对无法脱身。他接着说，他觉得在电影的这个阶段，巴士需要一个非常大的挑战，而且他们每天都在看着未完工的高速公路的一部分。
So he asked the writers to write in the movie that there would be an unfinished bridge. The studio told the director they thought this was ridiculous. They said a bus can't jump a bridge, but the director fought really hard for this moment. He said, listen, we need a big climactic moment for this bus and in a big emotional moment where everyone is terrified and then they feel like relief and victory almost. Now, to do this in real life, like we said, they stripped down the bus, they made it super duper light and they had stunt driver Joffrey Brown do this jump for real. He was driving the bus, not over a 50 foot gap, we should say, but they were going to
所以他要求编剧在电影里写进一座未完工的桥。制片厂告诉导演，他们觉得这太荒谬了。他们说巴士不可能飞跃桥梁，但导演为这个时刻进行了极力争取。他说，听着，我们需要为这辆巴士安排一个高潮迭起的大场面，在每个人都感到惊恐的情感高潮过后，几乎能感受到解脱和胜利。那么，要在现实中做到这一点，正如我们所说，他们拆解了巴士，把它改得超级无敌轻，并让特技车手杰弗里·布朗实打实地完成了这次飞跃。他开着巴士，我们要说明的是，不是飞越50英尺的鸿沟，而是他们打算
have him drive 70 miles an hour up a ramp and then sort of launch off this ramp and land on the other side of this ramp. And their biggest concern was that when the bus hit the ground that that pressure would compress his spine and maybe break his spine. So the stunt coordinator designed a special suspension safety harness to keep this from happening so that when the bus landed, he would be in like this like safety thing. I'm doing the motion, no one can see me. I can see it.
让他以每小时70英里的速度开上一个匝道，然后从这个匝道弹射出去，并降落在匝道另一侧。他们最大的担忧是，当巴士落地时，那种压力会压迫他的脊椎，甚至可能折断他的脊椎。所以特技统筹设计了一个专门的悬挂安全带，以防止这种情况发生，这样当巴士着陆时，他就会处于这样一个安全装置里。我在做动作，没人能看得见我。我看得见。
You see what I'm doing. It's selling it. It's selling it. Thank you. But then the other thing that they were concerned about was that they had some cameras that they were afraid might snap off their rigs and crush the driver. But they rehearsed this for two weeks. They did.
你知道我在做什么。太形象了。太形象了。谢谢。但随后他们担心的另一件事是，他们有一些摄像机，担心可能会从固定装置上脱落并砸死司机。但他们为此排练了两周。他们确实排练了。
They also put Joffrey, the driver, in the middle of the bus in like this cage, like you said, with this suspension bungee thing, because that way if the bus compressed in the front or the back, he would be in the center of it. They also had super suspension shocks on the bus to absorb some of that as well. And here's what Jan said. He said the effects people told him that the bus would only go about 30 feet max because the bus was just too big to jump any further than that. So he set his cameras up with that measurement in mind.
他们还把司机杰弗里放在巴士中央的一个笼子里，就像你说的，带着这个悬挂弹索装置，因为这样如果巴士前部或后部受到挤压，他都会处于中心位置。他们的巴士上还有超级减震弹簧，也可以吸收一部分冲击力。简是这么说的。他说特效人员告诉他，巴士最多只能飞大约30英尺，因为巴士太大了，不可能跳得比这更远。所以他在设置摄像机时把这个尺寸记在了心里。
And they were like a ton. Yeah. And then in reality, the bus actually flew over all of his cameras and landed on two of them, totally destroying one of them. He said thankfully he had put one camera 90 feet out because that's the one that caught the landing. They could not believe how far this bus actually flew. At its highest point, the front of it was 20 feet in the air.
而且它们重达一吨。是的。然后实际上，巴士直接飞过了他所有的摄像机，并砸中了其中两台，彻底摧毁了其中一台。他说幸好他把一台摄像机放在了90英尺外，因为就是那台拍下了落地的画面。他们简直不敢相信这辆巴士居然飞得这么远。在它的最高点，车头在空中达到了20英尺。
It actually went out of frame. You can see that in the movie. Yeah. Yes. It went far more vertical than they expected. And in reality, the bus stayed in the air for.49 seconds. But because they had all of these cameras and then they kind of slowed down the speed of the film, it stays in the air for 11 seconds in the movie.
它甚至飞出了画面。你在电影里能看到这一点。是的。是的。它比他们预期的要更加垂直。现实中，巴士在空中停留了0.49秒。但因为他们有所有这些摄像机，然后他们放慢了胶片的播放速度，所以在电影里它在空中停留了11秒。
Jan went on to say he really wanted to be able to show the passengers of the bus reacting to the landing. So they actually got another bus and rigged it to do a very, very small jump. He said it only went about eight inches in the air, but the actors had real reactions because even just eight inches, that's a big impact for a structure as big as a bus. And they said it was fun. It felt like a roller coaster. Wow.
简接着说，他真的很想展示巴士乘客对着陆的反应。所以他们实际上找了另一辆巴士，并进行了改装，让它做了一次非常非常小的跳跃。他说它在空中只飞了大约八英寸高，但演员们的反应是真实的，因为哪怕只有八英寸，对于像巴士这么大的结构来说也是一次巨大的冲击。他们说这很有趣。感觉就像坐过山车一样。哇。
One other thing, Jan, he had sort of said in the beginning, listen, we had cameras everywhere. We had pulleys. We had all of these rigs. It was impossible when we edited to sometimes not capture another camera. So I did do a pass called spot that camera. Okay. There are so many. Really?
还有一件事，简，他一开始就说过，听着，我们到处都有摄像机。我们有滑轮。我们有所有这些装置。剪辑时有时不可避免地会拍到另一台摄像机。所以我确实做了一遍名为“找找那台摄像机”的筛选。好吧。有好多呢。真的吗？
There are so many. There's one on the side of the road on a tripod, like a big camera. There's ones on the side of the bus. They try to make them kind of look like they're part of the bus, but like, I mean, listen, I'm sure you guys don't want to do this. You don't want to watch speed, just trying to look for cameras, but there were a lot. You could. You could.
有好多呢。路边有一个三脚架上的摄像机，像个大摄像机。巴士侧面也有。他们尽量让它们看起来像是巴士的一部分，但是，听着，我确信你们大家都不想这么做。你们可不想一边看《生死时速》一边只顾着找摄像机，但真的有很多。你可以的。你可以的。
Well, they do their jump and now they are headed to the airport, which is going to be great because they're going to be able to control things now. The bus can just drive in a giant circle. Well, in the original script, the bus was going to circle Dodger Stadium and then it was going to go on and it was going to blow up by the Hollywood sign. The writer Graham said that he actually looked at like an overview of Los Angeles and he was like, where can a bus go in a circle? And he saw the parking lot at Dodger Stadium, but the O'Malley's who owned Dodger Stadium
好吧，他们完成了飞跃，现在正朝机场开去，这太棒了，因为他们现在可以控制局面了。巴士可以直接在一个巨大的圆圈里行驶。好吧，在最初的剧本中，巴士将绕着道奇体育场转圈，然后继续行驶，并将在好莱坞标志附近爆炸。编剧格雷厄姆说，他实际上看了一份洛杉矶的鸟瞰图，他当时想，巴士能在哪里转圈呢？然后他看到了道奇体育场的停车场，但当时拥有道奇体育场的奥马利家族
at the time were not into it. They weren't into it. They weren't having it. They didn't know, so they changed it to the airport, which was actually really helpful because then as a story point, they could restrict all that, you know, the news cameras and all that. Yeah, the airspace. It worked great.
并不买账。他们不买账。他们不干。他们不知情，所以他们把地点改成了机场，这实际上真的很有帮助，因为作为一个故事支点，他们可以限制所有那些，你知道的，新闻摄像机以及所有这些。是的，空域。效果非常好。
Jack's going to get a phone call because the bomber has a cell phone now. His giant AT&T big handheld cell phone. Can we talk about his choice to hold the cell phone across his body? Oh, Dennis Hopper. Yeah. So, Dennis Hopper is holding it in his right hand, which is his undamaged hand. You know, his one hand, he lost his thumb in some sort of incident at work. Yeah.
杰克要接个电话，因为炸弹客现在有手机了。他那巨大的AT&T大号手持手机。我们能聊聊他把手机横过身体拿着的选择吗？哦，丹尼斯·霍珀。是的。所以，丹尼斯·霍珀是用右手拿的，那是他完好无损的手。你知道，他的一只手，在某种工作事故中失去了大拇指。是的。
So, he's holding the phone with his other hand, but then he crosses it over to his left ear. Why not just hold it up to your right ear? You know, the writers. I love it. I love it too. The writers and producers talked about this. They were like, why is he doing that?
所以，他是用另一只手拿着手机，但随后把它横过来贴在左耳上。为什么不直接举到右耳呢？你知道的，编剧们。我太喜欢了。我也很喜欢。编剧和制片人讨论过这个。他们当时想，他为什么要这么做？
Is this just a choice Dennis made? It wasn't in the script. I thought it was very specific, but it made me think like, okay, your phone rings. Answer your phone. Okay. Your phone's ringing. Hello. Which ear do you hold it up to?
这只是丹尼斯做出的选择吗？剧本里可没有。我觉得这非常具体，但它让我觉得，好吧，你的电话响了。接电话。好吧。你的电话在响。喂。你会把它举到哪只耳朵旁？
My right. With my right hand. Okay. I hold mine to my left ear. Oh. You do? With your left hand? Yeah.
我的右耳。用我的右手。好吧。我把手机贴在左耳上。哦。你真的吗？用你的左手？对。
But you're right handed. I know because a lot of times if I'm on the phone, I put it in the crick of my neck and I can do things with my right hand. I put it in my right crick and I can still do things with my hand. See, when I hold it up to my right ear, it feels so weird. It feels like the world's upside down. I wondered if maybe when that bomb went off and it took off his left thumb, maybe he got some damage in his ear.
但你是右撇子。我知道，因为很多时候如果我在打电话，我会把它夹在脖子窝里，这样我就可以用右手做事了。我把它夹在右边脖子窝里，我依然可以用手做事。你看，当我把它举到右耳时，感觉太怪了。感觉就像世界倒转了一样。我在想，也许当年那个炸弹爆炸炸掉了他的左大拇指时，他的耳朵也受了点伤。
Remember when I did my deep dive about loud explosions when we were breaking down Dwight K. Shrut? Yes. Acting manager? I thought maybe he had some hearing damage in that right ear and he needs to hold it up. That's very detailed backstory to give yourself. I would say this, I just thought Dennis Hopper liked to talk on his left side. I loved this choice.
还记得当我们剖析德怀特·K·施鲁特时，我做过关于巨响的深度探讨吗？记得。代理经理？我想也许他那只右耳有听力损伤，所以他需要把它举起来。给自己设定这样的背景故事可真够细节的。我会这么说，我只是觉得丹尼斯·霍珀喜欢用左侧接电话。我很喜欢这个选择。
I did too. I had problems with it. I thought it was brilliant. I thought it was brilliant. Jack is going to dismantle the bomb and he's going to do this by getting on a little, what is it? Well, he doesn't dismantle it. Well, he's going to try.
我也很喜欢。我对它有点意见。我觉得这太妙了。我觉得这太妙了。杰克要拆除炸弹，他要通过坐上一辆小车来完成，这是什么车？好吧，他并不是在拆除它。好吧，他要试试。
He's going to try. Yeah. And he has to get on a little... It is insanity. It is insanity by far. The director said he felt like this was one of the most dangerous stunts in the whole entire movie. 100%
他要试试。是的。而且他必须坐上一辆小……这太疯狂了。这绝对是极其疯狂。导演说他觉得这是整部电影中最危险的特技之一。百分之百。
But at one hour, 12 minutes and 33 seconds, Keanu Reeves actually goes under the bus. Yes, he does. On this little red cart with four wheels. They said these wheels were tiny. It was going fast. One of them could have blown. They could have had a tire blowout. Anything could have happened.
但在1小时12分33秒时，基努·里维斯真的钻到了巴士底下。是的，他确实钻了。坐在这个带四个轮子的红色小推车上。他们说这些轮子非常小。当时车开得很快。其中一个轮子可能会爆掉。他们的轮胎可能会爆胎。什么都有可能发生。
Gary, the stunt coordinator, really tried to take care of him. They had him on a pulley thing that they could yank him out if they needed to. There was a whole other part where Yon talked about this on his commentary. Jenna, oh my gosh, get ready for this. What? He said when Keanu went under the bus, he really wanted it to feel real. And he shared a story from his childhood. Okay.
加里，特技统筹，真的非常照顾他。他们用一个滑轮装置吊着他，如果有必要的话可以把他猛地拉出来。还有另一部分，简在随笔评论中谈到了这一点。珍娜，哦天哪，准备好听这个。什么？他说当基努钻到巴士底下时，他真的很想让那种感觉真实。他分享了一个童年的故事。好吧。
We already know he got stuck in an elevator and how he brought that to this movie. That tension. He shared this. He said, when I was a child, I fell out of my dad's car. We were crossing a bridge and I fell against the railing of the bridge and then I rolled back under the car and the car went over me. Not fast, but I was under it. I have remembered this for my whole life and I wanted to portray some of the things that
我们已经知道他曾被困在电梯里，以及他是如何把那种经历带进这部电影的。那种紧张感。他分享了这件。他说，当我还是个孩子的时候，我从我爸爸的车里掉了下来。我们当时正过桥，我撞到了桥上的栏杆，然后向后滚到了车底，车子从我身上轧了过去。虽然不快，但我确实在车底下。我一辈子都记着这件事，我想把基努钻到巴士底下时
I felt in this scene when Keanu went under the bus. Is Yon going to tell a story where like in his childhood, he dismantled a bomb or he was on like a runaway subway train? Maybe. I don't know. There ever been a more fateful match for a project? He said he had a tremendous amount of respect for Keanu because of what he did for this scene, his focus and just all of it.
我所感受到的某些东西在这一幕中表现出来。简会不会讲一个这样的故事：比如他在童年时拆过炸弹，或者他坐过失控的地铁列车？也许吧。我不知道。难道还能有比这更命中注定的项目搭档吗？他说他对基努有着极大的敬意，因为他为这一幕所做的一切、他的专注以及所有这一切。
He was very impressed. Well, I'll tell you who you could not have put under that bus and had them maintain their focus. Who? I guess maybe you, Angela. Yeah. I don't know. You know you.
他印象非常深刻。好吧，我来告诉你谁是绝对不能塞进那个巴士底下还能保持专注的。谁？我猜可能是你，安吉拉。是的。我不知道。你知道你自己。
Could you do it? I could fit in the cart very well. Because I'm sure. This is true. I wouldn't hang off. I was worried because it looked like his feet were hanging off, you know. I don't think any of me would hang off the cart, but I mean, I don't think I could go under the bus.
你能做到吗？我可以非常合适地待在推车里。因为我确信。确实如此。我不会悬空挂着。我当时很担心，因为看起来他的脚都悬在外面了，你知道的。我觉得我的任何部分都不会挂在车外面，但我的意思是，我觉得我不可能钻到巴士底下。
Woman who had panic attack on the ramp, freeway ramp, it cannot go under the bus. So I'm definitely not going under the bus, remembering any of my lines while I'm under there. Also, once he was under the bus, they did all of these shots where he was like messing with the bomb and those shots, they had him strapped to the under part of the bus. They had like a little, literally they had tied Keanu to the under part of the bus. All right. Listen, back in the office, the police office, Harry gets a break in the case.
这个在匝道、高速公路匝道上惊恐发作的女人，是绝对钻不了巴士底下的。所以我绝对不会钻到巴士底下，还在钻进去的时候去记任何台词。另外，一旦他到了巴士底下，他们拍了所有这些镜头，他在那里摆弄炸弹，在这些镜头中，他被绑在巴士的底部。他们就像用一个小东西，字面意义上把基努绑在了巴士底部。好了。听着，回到办公室，警察局里，哈里在案件上有了突破。
Yeah. We found our scumbag. We sure did. I want to shout out the woman in the office with Harry was played by Margaret Medina. She was very helpful in solving this case. Yeah. Mm-hmm. So Harry is like, stop dismantling the bomb.
是的。我们找到了那个混蛋。我们确实找到了。我要感谢和哈里一起在办公室里的那个女人，她由玛格丽特·梅迪纳饰演。她在侦破此案方面非常帮忙。是的。嗯哼。所以哈里说，别拆炸弹了。
I'm going to the source. We're going to his house. Sit tight. We got him. Yeah. He was under the bus. I want you guys to know location alert, the house that was Howard's house was a real house in a neighborhood near LAX.
我去找源头。我们去他家。原地待命。我们抓到他了。是的。他在巴士底下。我想让你们知道，地点警报，霍华德的房子是洛杉矶国际机场附近社区的一座真实的房子。
This was my question. Was this a movie set because no guys, the house is going to blow up. Yeah. Harry is going to die. And I wrote down, did they blow up a real house in a real neighborhood? What about all the other houses in the neighborhood? It was an actual house in a neighborhood near LAX, and they said they actually did very little damage.
这就是我的问题。这难道是电影布景吗？因为伙计们，房子要炸了。是的。哈里要死了。我当时记下了，他们是在一个真实的社区里炸毁了一座真实的房子吗？社区里的其他房子怎么办？那确实是洛杉矶国际机场附近社区的一座实际房屋，他们说其实造成的破坏非常小。
This is some movie magic. They purposely built fake walls in front of the old walls, fake windows in front of the real windows, and they blew up very little, they said. They had a lot of special effects to create debris, and the owners were able to live in it afterwards. I am shocked. That's amazing. Yeah.
这就是所谓的电影魔法。他们故意在旧墙前建造了假墙，在真窗户前安装了假窗户，他们说炸毁的部分非常少。他们运用了大量特效来制造废墟，房主们事后还能继续住在里面。我太震惊了。太棒了。是的。
I was going to call Jack and taunt him, and Jack is going to completely freak out at one hour, 23 minutes and two seconds. I thought Keanu's performance in this moment was so real and physical, and he just got really bad news about his best friend. Now, granted, we don't talk about Harry ever again. Ever again. Ever again. But in this moment, you really see how upset he was, and that's a big physical piece of
我要给杰克打电话嘲弄他，而在1小时23分02秒时，杰克彻底情绪崩溃了。我觉得基努在这场戏里的表现是那么真实、极具身体表现力，他刚刚得知了关于他挚友的糟糕透顶的消息。现在，当然啦，我们再也没有谈起过哈里。再也没有。再也没有。但在这一幕中，你真的能看到他是多么心烦意乱，这是他必须完成的大段形体表演，我觉得他做得非常出色。
acting that he had to do, and I thought he did a really good job. He did. Jack is now going to have an epiphany. Yes. Wildcat. He realizes that Howard can see them on the little closed-circuit bus camera thingy. Yeah. Keanu had to do some glance acting.
他确实做得很棒。杰克现在要灵光一现了。是的。野猫。他意识到可以通过闭路巴士小摄像机看到他们。是的。基努必须做一些眼神演技。
We've talked about that earlier. He had to glance to the sweatshirt, glance to the camera, glance, glance, aha. Yep. Mac is going to figure out that a news van nearby can make a video of what's happening inside of the bus. They're going to play it on a loop to trick Howard while they get everybody off the bus. The actors really did cross between these two moving buses. They literally just put a wooden plank, and they had to keep the two buses going the exact
我们之前讨论过这个。他必须看一眼运动衫，看一眼摄像机，看一眼，再看一眼，啊哈。没错。麦克将弄清楚附近的一辆新闻转播车可以拍下巴士内部发生的事情。他们将循环播放这段视频来愚弄霍华德，同时把所有人转移出巴士。演员们真的在两辆行进的巴士之间穿行。他们实际上只是搭了一块木板，而且必须让两辆巴士保持完全相同的
same speed so the board wouldn't fall. They had some wires there to yank people up, but the actors really did cross from bus to bus. The special effects supervisor, John Frazier, said that they originally made a treadmill that would go 50 miles an hour to do a lot of these little insert shots of the people's feet going across the little bridge or other shots in the movie, but that John said to him, what's the difference between falling off a treadmill going 50 miles an hour and falling onto the street?
速度，这样木板才不会掉下来。他们那里有一些用来把人拉上去的绳索，但演员们确实是从一辆巴士走到了另一辆巴士。特效主管约翰·弗雷泽说，他们最初制作了一个时速50英里的跑步机，用来拍摄许多这类特写镜头，比如人们的脚踩着小桥走过，或者是电影中的其他镜头，但约翰对他说，从一辆时速50英里的跑步机上摔下来和摔到街上有什么区别？
Yeah. They said no difference. It's basically the same. So John was like, then we're not going to use the treadmill. We're just going to do it for real. Yeah. I totally agree. I mean, just watch one YouTube video of people falling on their treadmills at home.
是的。他们说没有区别。基本上是一样的。所以约翰就说，那我们不用跑步机了。我们就来玩儿真的。是的。我完全赞同。我是说，只要看一个人们在家里从跑步机上摔下来的YouTube视频就知道了。
It never ends well. It does not. The tourist guy is going to fall, and then they kind of have to yank him up, and now Jack and Annie are stranded on the bus. They have a bar to put on the pedal to keep it going and some rope. Can I just say for a second here, this is some very intricate knot tying while under a huge amount of pressure. Well, the director said this movie would not be a movie set in Los Angeles without a surf
从来没有好下场。确实没有。那个游客要摔倒了，然后他们不得不把他拉上去，现在杰克和安妮被困在巴士上了。他们有一根杠杆可以踩在踏板上让它保持行驶，还有一些绳索。我能插一句吗，在压力巨大的情况下，这打结的技术可真够复杂的。好吧，导演说过，这部电影如果不包含冲浪板或滑板的桥段，就不能算是一部以洛杉矶为背景的电影。而在他的脑海里，当杰克和安妮踩上那块板飞驰而出时，你们懂的，他们是在巴士上冲浪。你们知道他们其实真的踩着那块板吗？我看着它，我能看出那绝对是基努。我不太确定是不是桑德拉·布洛克。哦，确实是。所以最开始他们滑到巴士底下并冲出去的那第一个镜头，是特技
board or a skateboard moment. And in his mind, when Jack and Annie get on that piece of panel and go flying out, they're surfing out of the bus, you guys. Did you know that they really did ride on that board? I was looking at it, and I could tell it was definitely Keanu. I wasn't sure if it was Sandra Bullock. Oh, it was. So the very beginning where they slide under the bus and go out, that first shot, are stunt
替身。好吧。但一旦他们到了开阔通畅的跑道上，那就是桑德拉·布洛克和基努·里维斯了。他们开得非常快。让我告诉你们他们是怎么说的。上面说这块板下面有小轮子，他们基本上就是把他们推出去然后放手，他们滑行的距离比想象的要远得多。
people. Okay. But then as soon as they're in the clear open of the runway, that's Sandra Bullock and Keanu Reeves. They're going very fast. Let me tell you what they said. It said the board had little wheels on it, and they basically just launched them and let them go, and they went way further than they thought they would go.
他们紧紧地抱在一起。我知道他们是的。他们真的是。巴士要爆炸了，因为它时速低于50英里了。它即将撞上一架飞机，但随后它爆炸了，继续撞向飞机，接着飞机爆炸了。我真的很喜欢这个细节，因为我很喜欢他们向我们展示了巴士上的炸弹是真的。
They are holding onto each other really tightly. I know they are. They really are. The bus is going to explode because it goes under 50 miles per hour. It's about to run into a plane, but then it explodes, keeps running into the plane, and then the plane explodes. And I really love that detail because I really liked that they showed us that the bomb on the bus was real.
它不只是撞上飞机然后就爆炸了。而是像，不，它以每小时49英里的速度行驶并爆炸了。然后它引爆了飞机，他们在机身侧面写了字来确保我们所有人都知道。这是一架货机。这不是客机。他们不可能用更大的字写出来了。他们甚至还用卡车拉着这架飞机。
It didn't just run into the plane and then they exploded. It was like, no, it went 49 miles an hour and it exploded. And then it exploded the plane, which they wrote on the side of the plane to make sure we all knew. It was a freight plane. This was not a passenger plane. They could not have written it in bigger letters. They even had the truck pulling the plane.
他们让那个家伙跳车逃跑，所以没有人受伤。那个逃跑的家伙是制片人伊恩·布莱斯。整个序列都是在沙漠中拍摄的。他们显然不可能在机场甚至实际的机场里炸毁一架飞机。整个序列都是在沙漠中拍摄的。此外，这架飞机装满了重型液体炸药，它带有一个滑轮系统，实际上还连接着巴士，并且把巴士拉向自己。哇。
They had the guy jump out and run away, so no one was hurt. The guy that ran away was a producer, Ian Brice. And this whole sequence was shot in the desert. They could not obviously blow up a plane at an airport in the actual airport. This whole sequence was shot in the desert. Also, the plane was full of heavy liquid explosives and it had a pulley system and it was actually attached to the bus and it was pulling the bus to itself. Wow.
是的。安妮开始哭了。她真的崩溃了。这一天过得。她刚踩着一块小木板从巴士里被弹射出去。我确实注意到，当杰克在安慰她时，他的手自始至终都放在她的胸口上。她胸部的哪个位置？
Yeah. Annie starts to cry. She really breaks down. It's been a day. She just went catapulting out of a bus on a tiny plank. I did notice that while Jack is comforting her, he just leaves his hand on her chest the whole time. What part of her chest?
就在正中间，正中央。安妮有句著名的台词。她说，我得警告你，我听说过基于极端情况建立的关系永远不会持久。这将在结尾以一种盛大的、蛮横的方式呼应回来。你以为事情已经结束了。而这本该是电影最初的结局，以巴士爆炸告终。是的。这本该是结尾。
It's just right in the middle there, right in the center. And Annie has this famous line. She says, I have to warn you, I've heard relationships based on intense situations never work. This is going to come back at the end in a big way, in a sassy way. You think things are over. And this is where the movie originally was going to end with the bus blowing up. Yes. This is going to be the end.
格雷厄姆在评论中说，电影到这里就结束了。然后我们有了第二部分，把这一切又重演了一遍。是的，在地铁上。这是我们电影中的最后一个序列。你知道的，我这时候已经累了。我不确定。尽管我爱你，《生死时速》，我爱你。我不知道我是否需要整个地铁的桥段，但制片厂觉得他们需要
Graham in the commentary says, this is when the movie ends. And then we have a second part where we do it all again. Yeah, on the subway. This is our final sequence in the movie. You know, I was tired at this point. I'm not sure. As much as I love you, Speed, I love you. I don't know if I needed the whole subway thing, but the studio felt that they needed
在最后一部分离开巴士。好吧。而且我们还需要抓住我们的坏蛋。是的。他还没解决呢。他还在逍遥法外。是的。是的。
to get off the bus for the final segment. Okay. And we also still need to catch our bad guy. Yeah. He's not been resolved. He's still out there. Yeah. Yeah.
所以他们要去放下他的赎金，就好像巴士还在兜圈子一样。他正看着他的小电视。他还没弄明白呢。他还没弄明白呢。不，他不知道。他还没看到钱包的故障呢。他们要把钱丢进位于洛杉矶市中心的潘兴广场街角的这个垃圾桶里。
So they're going to drop off his money as if the bus is still circling. He's looking at his little TV. He hasn't figured it out yet. He hasn't figured it out yet. No, he doesn't know. He hasn't seen the purse glitch yet. They're going to drop the money into this trash can on the corner here in Pershing Square, which is in downtown L.A.
安妮和杰克坐着救护车前往交钱的地点。我要对这一点胡扯一番。好吧。因为他们绝不会把安妮带到这个犯罪现场，经历这一切之后绝对不会。他们让她留在救护车里，但她需要呼吸点新鲜空气。救护车为什么不回医院？我不知道。
Annie and Jack ride in the ambulance to where the drop is going to happen. And I'm just going to call bullshit on that for a second. Okay. Because they would not take Annie to this act of crime scene, not after everything she's been through. They tell her to stay in the ambulance, but she needed some fresh air. Why didn't the ambulance go back to the hospital? I don't know.
杰克为什么不坐警车去现场，而让安妮坐救护车？对。他说，回头见。你知道为什么吗？为什么？因为霍华德·帕恩需要绑架安妮，由此拉开了我对这部各方面都很棒、拥有极其出色的女主角的电影的唯一一个巨大的女权主义吐槽的序幕，那就是她从这部电影中英勇的联合主角、联合英雄，变成了一个等待救援的弱女子。
Why didn't Jack get into a police car and go to this scene and Annie goes to an ambulance? Yeah. And he says, I'll see you later. You know why? Why? Because Howard Payne is going to need to kidnap Annie and thus begins my one giant feminist complaint about this otherwise really great movie with a terrific female lead, which is that she goes from being this heroic co-lead of this movie, this co-hero to being a damsel
你没有丢下我。是的。你没有丢下我。这让我很沮丧。她在地铁里是这么说的。是的。因为她够辣够酷了那么久，这本来是一件非常酷的事。
in distress. You didn't leave me. Yeah. You didn't leave me. It bummed me out. That's what she says in the subway. Yeah. Because she was so badass for so long and this was like a really cool thing.
顺便说一句，基努，另一个热爱基努的原因是，他在电影中似乎对与女性共享英雄角色没有任何问题。他确实没有。无论是《惊爆点》里的洛丽·佩蒂、《黑客帝国》还是《生死时速》。他在一次采访中确实说过他把她视为女主角。是的，她是。她确实是。好吧，他们搞不懂为什么钱一直没动。
And by the way, Keanu, another reason love Keanu, he does not seem to have a problem sharing the hero role with women in his movies. He doesn't. Lori Petty in Point Break, The Matrix, Speed. He does say in an interview that he saw her as a heroine. Yes, she is. She is. Well, they can't figure out why the money hasn't moved.
他们放下钱了。你知道，为什么钱没动呢？你知道吗？为什么他们一开始不把它打开？哦，因为那个自以为是的直男说教狂、自大狂、追踪器专家。诺伍德。是的。他就像，我不需要现在打开它。
They dropped it off. You know, why is the money not moving? You know? Why didn't they have it turned on at the beginning? Oh, because Mr. Man's splaining egomaniac, like, tracker guy. Norwood. Yeah. He's like, I don't need to turn it on yet.
我不需要打开它。我们一切都准备好了，它会爆炸的。我们有墨水爆炸装置。我们有追踪器。我们盯着箱子呢。我不需要打开它。他还没来呢。快把它打开。
I don't need to turn it on. We've got everything ready, it's going to explode. We've got like an ink explosion. We've got a tracker. We've got eyes on the box. I don't need to turn it on. He hasn't come yet. Just turn it on.
哦，你猜怎么着？它在动。它在动。地上有个洞。干得好，诺伍德。他突然对诺伍德这么生气。我知道。我看着的时候倒没有这种感觉，但现在我全身上下都是火。
Oh, guess what? It's moving. It's moving. There's a hole in the ground. Way to go, Norwood. He's suddenly so mad at Norwood. I know. I didn't feel that way when I was watching him, but now I'm all worked up.
现在我气死诺伍德了。基努就像，一意识到钱在动，他就冲出去了。你知道吗？杰克有时不等掌握全部信息。他了解了一点信息就直接冲了出去。他在这些飞驰的汽车中冲过了一个十字路口。基努真的是自己跑的。那些可都是特技车手。
Now I'm pissed off at Norwood. Keanu's like, the minute they realize it's moving, he's out the door. You know what? Jack doesn't wait to get all of the information sometimes. He gets a little bit of it and then he just runs. He ran across an intersection with these cars coming. Keanu really did that. Those were all stunt drivers.
而喜欢精彩动作戏的简其实对此很担心，并说他觉得这没必要。而基努却说，不，我想拍。哇。所以他真的拍了。我可以看这个男人跑很长时间。好吧，准备好，因为今天下午，我向你保证他会在《疾速追杀4》里到处狂奔。
And Jan, who loves a good action sequence, actually was worried about this and said that he didn't think it was necessary. And Keanu was like, no, I want to do it. Wow. So he did it. I could watch this man run for a long time. Well, get ready, because this afternoon, I guarantee you he's going to be running all over John Wick 4.
我知道。我有一些关于地铁的信息。我们讨论过他们是如何在一条未完工的高速公路上拍摄这部电影的大部分内容的。地铁也是未完工的。哦，我甚至没提到他们拍摄洛杉矶国际机场的那部分时，那里正在施工。而且没完工。这些人太走运了。所以三个主要取景地当时都在建设中，并且拥有这些没有公众的空置空间。
I know. I have some information about the Subway. We talked about how they filmed most of this movie on an unfinished freeway. The Subway was also unfinished. Oh, I didn't even mention the part of LAX they filmed at was in construction. And unfinished. These guys lucked out. So three major locations were being built and had these empty spaces without public.
简说，当他们在地铁的实际部分拍摄时，他们只有一小段轨道，所以他们只能来回、来回、来回地跑。是的。当我们进入整个地铁打斗戏时，地铁车厢顶部是假的。这可以说是电影中唯一真正在带有绿幕的摄影棚里拍摄的部分，也就是杰克和霍华德在地铁车顶上的那场终极决斗。是的。
Jan said that when they did film in the actual part of the Subway, that they had a very small piece of track, so they just have to go back and forth and back and forth. Yeah. When we get down into the whole Subway fight, the top of the Subway car was fake. That was sort of like the one part of the movie that they actually did in a studio with green screen and all that stuff, that final fight between Jack and Howard on top of the Subway. Yeah.
而且简当时拿着摄像机，手持着在地铁车顶上拍摄。这太疯狂了。我们的炸弹客终于要走向灭亡了。他要人头落地了。他要人头落地了。然后基努要跳进地铁车厢里。你知道，安妮被手铐铐在这个柱子上，但他将非常迅速且轻易地拆除那个炸弹背心。
And Jan was holding the camera, handheld, filming on the roof of the Subway. That's crazy. Our bomber is finally going to meet his demise. He's going to lose his head. He's going to lose his head. And then Keanu is going to jump down into the Subway car. You know, Annie has been handcuffed to this pole, but he's going to very quickly and easily disconnect the bomb, the vest.
只需要猛地扯断那根电线，非常简单。这就是他干的事。这就是他干的事。好吧。他知道该怎么做。好吧。好吧。嗯，炸弹拆掉了，但他却无法把她从那个柱子上解救下来。
It was very easy to just yank that wire suddenly. This is what he does. This is what he does. Okay. He knows how to do this. Okay. All right. Well, the bomb is off, but he cannot get her off that pole.
钥匙在霍华德的口袋里。他已经人头落地了。他已经人头落地了。所以地铁就在这条轨道上横冲直撞。好吧，司机被霍华德枪击了。顺便说一句，司机由理查德·希夫饰演，他后来在《白宫风云》中扮演托比·齐格勒。哦，哇。是的。
The keys were in Howard's pocket. He's lost his head. He's lost his head. So the Subway is just careening down this track. Well, the driver had been shot by Howard. The driver, by the way, Richard Schiff, who went on to play Toby Ziegler in the West Wing. Oh, wow. Yeah.
他在这一部里甚至连一句台词都没有。没有。不过他有一场很棒的死亡戏。杰克想到了一个主意，他要给列车加速。这会让列车冲出轨道。是的。就是这个主意。我们来吧。
He didn't even have any lines in this one. Nope. He had a great death scene, though. Jack gets the idea that he's going to speed up the train. This is going to make the train jump the track. Yes. That's the idea. Here we go.
我们要飞跃别的东西了。所以这些地铁在轨道上飞驰的镜头，是一个他们搭建的模型，又是一个制作精良的模型。非常棒。他们建造的实际地铁列车重达105磅，时速可达15英里。太惊人了。它必须撞毁，他们必须精心编排这一切，因为最后冲出来的那个部分必须和巴士的尺寸完全一致，因为他们用了一辆真实的巴士，并
We're going to jump something else. So these scenes of the subway flying through the track, that was a miniature that they built, again, an elaborate miniature. It's very good. The actual subway train they built weighed 105 pounds and could go 15 miles an hour. Amazing. It had to break into, they had to orchestrate that because the part that goes shooting out at the end had to be the exact size of a bus because they took an actual bus and they built
在它外面搭建了一个外观，让它看起来像地铁。哦，因为我想他们不可能发射一辆地铁车厢。他们做不到。我刚才提到的这个特技的特技车手叫布莱恩。他也待在那个带有悬挂安全带的笼子里。哦，真聪明。疯狂的是这个。
an exterior around it to look like a subway. Oh, because I guess they couldn't launch a subway car. They couldn't. And the stunt driver for this stunt I mentioned earlier was Brian. He was also inside that cage with the suspended harness. Oh, smart. Here's the crazy thing. Because a subway doesn't have like a windshield, he had the very tiny little window to see
因为地铁没有挡风玻璃，他只有一个非常小的窗户向外看以完成飞跃。这太荒谬了。是的。这次飞跃非常顺利。相当疯狂。他们是在好莱坞大道上拍摄的。是的。由于有太多的游客，这是一个非常难以封锁的取景地。
out to make the jump. That is bonkers. Yeah. The jump did go off without a hitch. It's pretty wild. They did this in Hollywood Boulevard. Yeah. It was a very hard location to lock down because of all the tourists.
而且地铁巴士本应，你知道的，飞越空中并在星光大道观光车前停下来。是的。但在拍摄当天，它实际上一路滑行撞了进去，并轻轻地撞上了它，车身前后晃动。里面好像还有人呢。是的。我的意思是，它几乎只是轻触了一下。
And the subway bus is supposed to, you know, fly through the air and come to a stop right before the Starline Tour van. Yes. But on the day, it actually skidded all the way into it and gently hit it and it rocks back and forth. There were like people in it. Yes. I mean, it barely tapped it.
好吧。但那不是计划好的。为了拍成这个，他们不得不封锁了好莱坞的四个街区。哇。你知道当时的交通状况是什么样的。我知道。所以最后一幕，安妮和杰克。是的。
Okay. But that was not planned. They had to shut down four blocks of Hollywood to make this happen. Wow. You know what the traffic was like. I do. So the final scene, Annie and Jack. Yeah.
他们并肩躺在这个撞毁的地铁车厢里。在好莱坞的中心，杰克现在要把她的台词还给她了。我得警告你，我听说过基于极端情况建立的关系永远不会持久。她说，好吧，那我们只能基于性爱来建立关系了。哇。他说，随你便，长官。哇。然后一百万人聚集过来围观他们亲热，职员表滚动。
They're laying together in this crashed out subway car. In the middle of Hollywood, Jack is now going to say her line back to her. I have to warn you, I've heard relationships based on intense situations never work. She says, okay, then we'll just have to base it on sex. Whoa. And he says, whatever you say, ma'am. Whoa. And then a hundred people gather around to take pictures of them making out credits roll.
职员表滚动。就是这样。《生死时速》。那是《生死时速》，不是最低时速。全速。是的。我很享受。这部电影经得起时间的考验。
Credits roll. There you have it. Speed. That was speed, not minimum speed. Full speed. Yes. I enjoyed it. This movie holds up.
这部电影甚至经得起一周内看七遍的审视。这是一次非常有趣的旅程。确实如此，我真不敢相信你和我现在对这部电影了解了这么多信息。我真心希望我们能受邀参加鸡尾酒会，然后我们就能大谈特谈关于《生死时速》的信息。我敢肯定我们周围的人会想，他们为什么对这部电影知道这么多？
This movie even holds up to the scrutiny of watching it seven times in one week. It was such a fun ride. It really was and I can't believe how much information you and I both know about this movie now. I really hope we're invited to a cocktail party and we can just grow out some information about speed. I'm sure the people around us will be like, why the hell did they know so much about this movie?
别再跟我们聊这个了。是的。我不知道那是什么派对。我不知道这是什么活动，但好吧。不过，我确信我们会在那场派对上大放异彩。非常感谢大家收听。我完全推荐《生死时速》。办公室女士认证。
Stop talking to us about it. Yeah. I don't know what that party is. I don't know what this event is, but yeah. Well, I'm sure we'll dazzle at that party. Thank you guys so much for listening. I totally recommend speed. Office ladies approved.
好了。我们爱你们。我们下周再见，开始第八季，《名单》。我有一些关于选秀和詹姆斯·甘多菲尼的非常有趣的趣闻。我们在对雷恩的采访中谈过，但我们迫不及待想让你们听到。而且我会带回更多简谈论一些动作戏的音频剪辑。你会把这些点缀进《名单》里。
All right. We love you guys. We will see you next week for the beginning of season eight, the list. I've got some really fun tidbits about casting and James Gandolfini. We talked about it in our interview with Rain, but we can't wait for you to hear it. And I'm going to bring back some more audio clips of Jan talking about some of the action sequences. You're going to sprinkle that into the list.
我会把它们点缀进去的。好的。听起来不错。祝大家有个愉快的一周。拜拜。拜拜。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。
I'm going to sprinkle those in. All right. Sounds good. You guys have a great week. Bye. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey.
我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔担任执行制片人。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾尼斯莉·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。有关《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用优惠码：OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。
Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本节目由科迪·费舍尔担任执行制片人。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯，音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，助理制片人是艾因斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。要收听《办公室女士》的无广告版，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用 Stitcher Premium 一个月，请使用优惠码 OFFICE。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。